ils ont l'habitude de nous raconter le
monde ce soir Philippe Tamara AZ
Frédéric marié et Raphaël nous raconte
leur monde
[Musique]
Afghanistan c'est face à une sécheresse
d'une ampleur qui n'a pas connu
[Musique]
il y a 14
un sentiment de déjà-vu une somme qui
revient sans cesse après une fusillade
aux États-Unis
qui décidera du prochain pas à franchir
les funérailles d'Elisabeth II Marc
officiellement la fin d'un chapitre de
l'histoire
au Royaume-Uni l'inflation a augmenté de
plus de 10% à New York c'est la flambée
des prix vu le contexte économique les
organismes d'aide alimentaire prévoir
répondre à une demande importante des
vigiles armés surveillent les électeurs
il suffit seulement d'un seul siège
c'est tout le système électoral qui est
en jeu un président réélu la principale
discussion du Royaume-Uni l'avenir de
Boris Johnson
il y a à peine quelques semaines elle
manifestait dans les rues d'Iran
[Applaudissements]
la dépression c'est un mot qui revient
souvent dans les conversations avec les
femmes afghane
d'états ont déjà bandit les avortements
on rapporte des bruits d'explosion on
voit des tanks sortir
le missile est tombé ici les rues sont
pratiquement désertes c'est la trame
sonore de leur apocalypse
sans y avoir aucune méthode on frappe de
la Russie
de réfugiés des gens ne cessent d'entrer
en Pologne au moins elles sont encore en
vie ce qui laisse derrière c'est l'enfer
des civils tués une fausse commune La
guerre est une horreur peu importe la
couleur qu'on brandit
bonsoir madame messieurs bienvenue à en
direct du monde Céline Galipeau devait
être avec vous ce soir pour notre
émission spéciale et les frappée
d'ailleurs comme plusieurs d'entre vous
à la maison par le vilain virus de
l'influenceur évidemment Céline on la
cible de tout cœur avec tout je pense
que peut-être si chez elle devant son
écran bonsoir Céline et nous sommes de
tout cœur avec toi en direct du monde
c'est une émission conçue pour vous pour
parler des coulisses du métier on dit
familièrement que les correspondants à
l'étranger sont nos yeux nos oreilles
dans le monde ils sont tellement
essentiels à notre vie démocratique mais
comment ont-ils vécu ces événements
habituellement ils sont derrière la
nouvelle ils nous envoient des images
des textes très émouvants parfois même
très éprouvant mais ce soir ils ont
accepté généreusement qu'on jette la
lumière sur eux et leur travail parce
que oui être correspondant aux
correspondante à l'étranger
extraordinaire aventure journalistique
mais ça vient aussi avec une énorme
responsabilité pour bien servir le
public alors bonsoir à vous tous à vous
6 qui représenté dans le fond toute la
vigueur de Radio-Canada en information
internationale je vous annonce on a fait
le bilan 49 pays visités cette année
pour couvrir les événements pour
souligner l'importance de l'information
je salue le public en studio également
bienvenue le public va poser des
questions mais d'abord un premier tour
de table c'est un choix difficile on
vous a demandé une image qui était très
marquante pour vous parmi toutes celles
que vous nous avez fait parvenir puisque
commence avec vous-même c'est un choix
difficile des chirant même mais je
dirais que s'il y a une image que je
retiens qui me hante même peut-être
c'est celle de cette jeune fille en
Afghanistan
dont le père avait été contraint en fait
il l'a vendu pour combler des dettes et
qui s'accrochent à ces robes elle sait
très bien ce qu'il attend et elle ne
veut pas partir elle s'accroche comme ça
à son père on va évidemment y revenir au
cours des deux prochaines heures alors
Raphaël l'image que j'ai choisi c'est
cet enfant que traversé au tout début de
la guerre la frontière entre l'Ukraine
et la Pologne pour aller rejoindre ses
proches on voit l'image il quittait ce
pays en guerre et si tu te rappelles
aussi que ce conflit là a touché
également l'Europe il y a eu toutes
sortes de conséquences en Europe avec
l'accueil de réfugiés la crise
énergétique ça nous a beaucoup occupé
cette année cette image je trouve
parce que vous vous seul vous allez
visiter 10 pays en Europe pour bien
nous parler de cette guerre et Philippe
de l'asile lointaine quand même oui une
scène poste apocalyptique j'avais
l'impression de me retrouver dans un
film de science-fiction de zombies tapis
qui est une capitale grouillante 6
millions de personnes et qui étaient
complètement déserte pendant 30 minutes
j'étais au milieu d'une rue qui
normalement serait super passante on
faisait un exercice d'évacuation en cas
d'invasion et ça démontre à quel point
la démocratie la liberté tout ce qu'on a
c'est très fragile et puis ça nous
rapproche de la situation Ukraine aussi
même si vous êtes très loin merci alors
il y a beaucoup d'images qui viennent à
l'esprit une qui m'a particulièrement
marqué c'est après une tornade ou
kentaki en 20 secondes plusieurs maisons
ont été rasées et c'est l'image de cette
petite fille c'est drôle parce qu'on
c'est les enfants qui nous touchent
beaucoup qui balaient le perron du de la
maison de sa grand-mère qui est qui
s'est envolée qui est décédée et puis la
maison est complètement détruite et elle
elle continue à nettoyer elle nous dit
elle gardait toujours ça très propre et
elle est au milieu d'une désolation tout
autour d'elle donc ça c'est ça c'est
assez marquant puis c'est les
conséquences des changements climatiques
et sa génération évidemment va
malheureusement aussi bien les
conséquences puis on le voit encore
aujourd'hui même l'actualité nous le
prouve bien Frédéric ce sont des images
du crâne j'étais là-bas au mois de juin
et ce sont les images d'un bar au
centre-ville de Kiev où on voit des
Ukrainiens de tous les horizons qui sont
là qui dansent comme s'il y avait pas de
lendemain au sein de la musique cubaine
et d'une façon pour eux de montrer que
dans le fond vous n'aurez pas notre
notre côté mental oui c'est vrai on est
la cible de bombardements on entendait
les sirènes aussi à l'extérieur mais
c'est de dire à la Russie regardez on
continue de vivre parce que c'est
important c'est une un acte de
résistance dans l'enfant la vie plus
fort que tout est Tamara mais moi
c'était un Russie mais l'image lie ici
j'ai mal eu malheureusement dû l'effacer
parce que c'est interdit de tourner des
des soldats en Russie et donc on
l'effacait à la demande du FSB mais
c'est à 5 6h du déclenchement de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine on était dans
une ville frontalière en Russie tout
près de l'Ukraine et dans un dépanneur
des soldats de 18-19 ans qui faisait la
file pour s'acheter des bonbons Haribo
comme on achète à nos enfants et qui
utilisaient le dépanneur ce qui
ressemble à un dépanneur pour brancher
leur téléphone et retourner après ça à
leur tank qui était à l'extérieur et je
trouve que si l'image qui me hante pas
pour les mêmes raisons que Marie-Ève
mais parce qu'on connaît la suite on
traversait en Ukraine le soir même on
sait pas ce qui leur est arrivé ça avait
peut-être pas quelle était leur mission
et ça nous dit beaucoup aussi sur leur
niveau leur manque de préparation de
cette chaîne
pas loin dans votre bouche en effet
alors vous avez compris que c'est le
sujet que dominé la dernière année qui
va continuer de nous occuper de nous
préoccuper la garantie graine qui à
cette date l'an dernier croyait vraiment
qu'on se retrouverait en guerre il y
avait beaucoup de de déni d'abord ce
rappel en images
la Russie ne montre toujours pas de
signes de désescalade
[Musique]
nous dit-on ils ont dit qu'il faut pas
s'inquiéter impossible de se détacher de
l'atmosphère militaire qui règne malgré
tout la voix diplomatique n'est toujours
pas épuisée
est en train de se produire
[Musique]
une attaque concertée par la Russie tout
est arrivé très rapidement nous on est
sur le terrain et on voit l'arsenal
militaire cette attaque Vladimir Poutine
l'avait décidé il y a très longtemps
alors le président a déclenché l'état
d'urgence les Ukrainiens n'ont pas
l'intention de laisser faire sans
opposer une résistance importante
non on revie cette nuit du déclenchement
vous l'avez vécu sur place pour vous
marier c'est toujours important d'être
au bon endroit au bon moment et vous
étiez à
on était à Ken en fait on venait tout
juste de rentrer de l'Est du pays parce
qu'avant que l'invasion
ne soit déclenchée par Vladimir Poutine
il y avait quand même une guerre qui
avait cours en Ukraine depuis 2014 et là
les combats étaient très présents il y
avait des bombardements constants dans
des quartiers habités et on était allé
passer beaucoup de temps on avait
sillonné le pays aussi juste avant pour
prendre le pouls des Ukrainiens pour
voir mais au moment où on sentait quand
même liminant du déclenchement de la
guerre on a pris la décision de rentrer
vers la capitale et ça c'est toujours un
peu le choix déchirant c'est une de nos
plus grandes craintes je pense comme
journaliste c'est de ne pas arriver à
être au bon endroit au bon moment et
dans un pays comme une crainte qui est
quand même assez vaste qui demande des
heures et des heures de déplacement ça
peut être une source d'angoisse assez
importante parce qu'on peut imaginer le
pire mais on va en parler le pire est
arrivé finalement et de l'autre côté de
la frontière de l'autre côté là où
c'était on se demandait ce qui allait se
passer vous vous l'avez vu comment cette
semaine que la guerre à la frontière et
nous on savait qu'il fallait pas bouger
de là parce qu'on voyait on les a vu
dans l'image dans les images les les
chars se déployer les soldats et on
parle de dizaines de milliers de soldats
le soir même c'était toujours férié en
Russie c'était le jour du défenseur de
la patrie il y avait des feux d'artifice
à la fête dans tous les villages
environnants et je pense que on veut pas
y croire jusqu'à ce que ça se produit
ils ont dit toujours il va avoir une
tractation quelconque il va voir quelque
chose qui va se produire qui va faire en
sorte qu'on n'aura pas cet évasion à
grande échelle que les Américains
étaient convaincus qu'elle est arrivée
donc moi j'étais à l'hôtel et je me
couchais pas on attendait un discours de
Vladimir Poutine et Marie-Eve qui avait
passé la nuit debout la veille à
conduire justement pour revenir de l'est
de l'Ukraine dis-moi je dois aller me
coucher un peu et à ce moment-là vous
avez le droit de dormir mais c'est rare
mais il faut en fait il faut prendre
l'occasion de dormir quand on peut faire
et à ce moment-là nous on a reçu une
alerte sur le téléphone du côté russe
qu'on fermait l'espace aérien et c'est
là que j'ai appelé à Montréal c'est mon
et puis je pense qu'après ça on n'a pas
arrêté pendant deux trois jours et puis
parler moi il est anxieux
vous savez votre métier suscite
énormément de curieux c'était les gens
veulent savoir ce que votre comment vous
le faites comment ça se passe sur le
terrain tous les risques vous prenez on
a une question de Madame Fisette madame
Fisette bienvenue merci d'être là merci
beaucoup bonsoir comment fonctionner au
niveau logistique lorsque vous êtes
déployé en zone hostile et quels sont
vos plus grandes appréhensions sur le
terrain et vous étiez l'arrivée de
craindre pour votre sécurité merci de
votre question est très importante on va
la prendre en deux temps si vous voulez
bien parlons d'abord de la dimension
logistique parce que vous venez nous
dire vous vouliez être là au bon endroit
au bon moment et vous étiez vous aussi
au bon endroit au bon moment témoins de
ce que vivait les Russes
logistiquement là qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé là au moment où vous apprenez les
premières attaques le défi c'est des
choses qu'on fait avant qu'on les
apprenne parce que même si on espérait
jusqu'a le dernier instant qui est pas
cette invasion on se prépare ça c'est la
base la première des préoccupations elle
est toujours sécuritaire c'est-à-dire
que quand on se déploie on s'assure
qu'on a des équipements de sécurité des
gilets par balles des casques téléphone
satellite parce qu'on sait pas si les
télécommunications vont tenir ou pas
après pour la suite tout ce qui est où
est-ce qu'on va dormir manger comment ça
dépend beaucoup des terrains qu'on va
couvrir est-ce qu'on pense qu'on risque
de manquer d'eau de nourriture c'est pas
toujours le cas il faut pas penser qu'on
meurt de faire chaque fois qu'on est
déployé généralement ça c'est une des
dernières choses qui tombent quand on
est déployé mais quand même il faut
pouvoir prévoir se nourrir nous pouvoir
nourrir les équipes qui travaillent avec
nous donc on réfléchit à ces questions
là puis on a juste dans le cas de
l'Ukraine à un moment on s'est dit ben
ça prend un générateur parce que
l'électricité on en noterait peu on ne
sait jamais si on peut compter dessus
donc à ce moment-là on s'achète un
générateur et puis il faut penser
peut-être un ou deux coups d'avance
parfois ça veut dire qu'on est sur
préparé mais au moins on manque de rien
des conseillers en sécurité qui vous
accompagnent également dans chacun et là
vous Tamara vous êtes quand même dans le
pays vu d'ici le pays agresseur
paysanner ça a changé d'une minute à
l'autre tout a changé au lendemain notre
capacité en tant qu'équipe dont la
priorité est de rapporter de travailler
dramatiquement notre situation c'est à
dire que du jour au lendemain vous savez
notre carte de guichet nous n'a pas de
carte de guichet en plastique tout est
sur à pompé mais ça c'était banni en
Russie
on pouvait même pas aller à l'épicerie
ou à la station-service payer l'essence
avec avec notre téléphone notre capacité
de transférer de l'argent de Montréal
vers la Russie
non-existante ça c'est des choses pour
lesquelles on sait de préparer mais
clairement on n'avait pas la capacité de
rester des semaines et des semaines en
Russie une fois que les sanctions ont
été annoncés l'autre volet de la
question de Madame fusée c'était bien
sûr la mesure du risque du danger que
vous prenez sur le terrain vous tous ici
là et on a retenu un cours extrait qui
vous touche Tamara et Marie-Ève sur le
terrain parce que vous allez à la
rencontre des gens sur le terrain et
donc vous êtes aussi la cible parfois on
écoute
[Musique]
ici on n'est pas dans la science-fiction
Marie-Ève nous on est dans la sécurité
de notre studio on vous écoute au
Téléjournal pensez que vous avez vécu ça
comment on prend la mesure du danger
comme on accepte de prendre le risque
parce que vous acceptez de prendre le
risque je pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'on fait avant même de partir c'est
pas le premier conflit que je couvre
c'est pas les premières zones où il y a
des combats très intenses où je me
déplace et c'est je pense que c'est une
discussion qu'on a avec soi-même avant
même de partir maintenant une fois qu'on
est sur place cette scène là en fait je
disais que la guerre elle avait cours
dans l'est du pays avant même que
l'invasion arrive et ça c'est dans le
don de base avant l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie et c'est vous
dites on était la cible non mais on
était avec des militaires à ce moment-là
on visitait des endroits qui étaient
près d'une ligne de tranchées de l'armée
ukrainienne il y avait des bombardements
on s'est mis à l'abri c'était des tirs
de mortier
ça reste qu'il y a toujours une part
très aléatoire dans la couverture on se
prépare on a des conseillers en sécurité
qui nous accompagnent qui peuvent
identifier certains des dangers
peut-être plus facilement que nous
mais après il faut aussi réagir aux
situations dans la semaine qu'on voit
Tamara si tu as 800 mètres de vous ou il
est tombé et c'était moi j'ai beaucoup
moins en toute transparence d'expérience
en zone de guerre que Marie-Ève donc je
voudrais même que c'était presque un
batteur pour moi
je pense que je le vis moins bien que
que ma reine de bien le vivre je sais
pas comment elle le vit mais ce que les
gens voient pas et ça on le montre parce
que nous on veut pas montrer notre
réalité nécessairement sont le pas
montrer cet extrait là en ondes dans les
reportages là vous le montrez parce que
c'est important aussi d'expliquer quand
on va dans une ville comme une collage
qui était la cible de Data tous les
jours
on a un conseiller en sécurité là est-ce
que tout le monde est à l'aise d'entrer
à Nicolas oui oui
j'entends ça qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
donc je savais que ça c'était
probablement des tirs qui partaient d'où
on était vert
vers
les Russes mais il y a un oui moi je le
vis moins bien mais il y a pas de
panique c'est ça qui est intéressant
puis ça ça nous sauve dans la majorité
alors vous étiez littéralement sur les
lieux mais cette guerre est devenue une
guerre d'usure dans la durée dans les
stratégies tout ça et vous l'avez vécu
de différentes manières Philippe vous un
peu plus tard va vous être rendu à
élever totalement
il y avait tout l'autre volet de cette
guerre là qui était les déplacés les
gens qui devaient aller chercher refuge
quelque part ils vivent qui était la
plaque tournante donc moi ce que j'ai vu
c'est l'entraide c'est le premier
mouvement la résistance comme on le
pouvait aller aider les soldats au front
en construisant certaines denrées en
leur acheminant mais l'image qui me
rappelle que tout le monde a essayé de
faire sa part à sa façon c'est notre
fixeur qui nous a accompagnait
qui fait la recherche qui nous
accompagne qui fait de la traduction et
on va donner on tourne dans un théâtre
où on recevait des réfugiés il le vu un
piano et on dit toujours que les
Ukrainiens sont immensément l'art
musical il a joué une mélodie improvisée
qui illustrait parfaitement ce que
ressentait les ukrainiens et leurs désir
je pense on l'entend très bien dans ces
notes là de faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour résister montrer qu'ils sont encore
là
pour vous Raphaël aussi vous qui avez
couvert aussi la guerre
les conséquences de cette guerre
exactement parce que on les ressent
partout en Europe nous d'abord au début
du conflit on couvrait davantage les
réactions diplomatiques et beaucoup
d'annulation de déplacement de billets
de train parce que bon rencontre annuler
entre le ministre russe des Affaires
étrangères secrétaires d'État américain
on y va pas finalement la guerre est
déclenchée puis on décide d'aller en
Pologne parce que c'est un pays qui
partage une frontière énorme avec
l'Ukraine et on se doutait qu'il allait
avoir un grand nombre de réfugiés qui
allait se rendre en Pologne et à partir
de ce moment-là pendant quoi une
vingtaine un peu plus de jours on a
décidé de se promener un peu partout
pour constater les impacts de cette
guerre puis on a vraiment décidé au fur
et à mesure de voir quel impact on
allait décider de couvrir bon il y avait
la question des réfugiés qui est
importante mais très rapidement on est
aussi par exemple aller en Finlande où
il y avait le débat sur l'adhésion à
l'OTAN qui s'est rapidement imposé un
truc qu'on n'aurait pas pensé possible
quelques semaines auparavant donc on a
vu rapidement sur le terrain ces impacts
de la guerre c'est important c'est
crucial même que mes collègues la
couvrent sur le terrain mais c'était
aussi important de voir sur un continent
comme l'Europe qu'elle a des impacts
majeurs et c'est encore le coup parce
qu'on en parlera tout à l'heure mais on
se demande si au fond c'est devenu notre
guerre aussi puis si votre travail c'est
le prolongement de politique étrangère
canadienne on peut on aura l'occasion de
se parler de cette question là parce que
c'est ce qu'on est bon il y a les
méchants quand on est sur le terrain
mais les trains vous ont marqué les
trains
quand on est en Pologne donc à l'est de
la Pologne dans des plaines il faisait
plutôt froid et vantait puis on a ces
tringles qui datent d'une autre époque
d'ailleurs qui arrive avec un très grand
nombre de réfugiés qui fuient la guerre
à l'intérieur c'est très quitter levé
vous se trouvait Philippe moi je suis
peut-être l'autre côté puis les gens
fuyaient la guerre comme ça c'est le
genre de scène qu'on n'aurait pas cru
possible en Europe à cette époque aussi
donc la Seconde Guerre mondiale on est
très servait à autre chose et si c'est
marquant pour nous seul aussi pour
les gens qui vivent en Europe et pour
vous Frédéric la difficulté c'est sûr
que moi j'étais quand même quelques mois
après le début de la guerre donc c'est
sûr que le focus de mon travail sur
place c'est de montrer un petit peu mais
mais comment vivent les Ukrainiens en
dehors de la zone de guerre et comment
ils essayent quand même de vivre malgré
tout et donc c'était comme des galeries
de portraits très intéressantes d'un
rapport par exemple qui est très connu
qui qui fait des chansons sur sur le
drame qui touche son pays et qui ensuite
le lendemain prend son arme
semi-automatique sa mitraillette et s'en
va au front parce que c'est comme ça
qu'il qu'il veut faire sa part pour le
pays
l'engagement des Ukrainiens quel que
soit leur rôle dans leur
fierté les artistes aussi que j'ai
rencontré qui eux faisaient mal ils
essaient de faire des représentations
théâtrales pour amasser de l'argent pour
donner un coup de pouce à ces militaire
là c'est soldats Ukrainiens très très
rapidement
parce qu'on s'éloigne un peu du terrain
de la guerre mais vous étiez aux
États-Unis et le seul
chef d'État qui parlait de la
probabilité de cette guerre là où il y
avait peut-être une certitude c'était
bidule tout à fait en fait bien avant le
23 février 24 février ils annonçaient
qu'il allait avoir une guerre il disait
dans quelques jours ça peut arriver d'un
moment à l'autre mais quand on écoutait
le côté rue il disait qu'ils étaient
encore en train de négocier puis à
l'époque on parlait du fait que pour les
Russes il ne voulait pas avoir à leur
porte les troupes de l'OTAN c'était tout
le débat de l'Ukraine il fallait pas que
l'Ukraine entre dans l'OTAN et le débat
qu'on avait aux États-Unis c'était que
bon bah le temps c'est la politique des
portes ouvertes quiconque va adhérer peu
donc on était encore dans la diplomatie
mais concrètement il disait que ça va
arriver d'un moment à l'autre du côté
russe il disait que c'était carrément
une hystérie mais les Américains étaient
persuadés puis là où il y a eu quelque
chose quand même d'assez inédit aux
États-Unis c'est qu'en fait ils ont
carrément révélé tout ce qu'ils avaient
normalement c'est des dossiers qui sont
classifiés classés et là il disait
écoutez Poutine va trouver un prétexte
il va prétendre qu'ils ont été attaqués
et donc ils vont répondre à et nos
troupes vont et se trouve vont envahir
l'Ukraine parce qu'il nous disaient ils
disaient les chiffres qui avaient 100
000 soldats à la frontière
donc on se posait la question et donc on
a une autre question c'est Monsieur
touchette bonsoir Monsieur bienvenue
merci à tous pour votre travail
maintenant ma question serait en 2002 il
y a eu différents conflits armés dans le
monde le crève nous on en a parlé et
aussi en Éthiopie au Yémen etc pourtant
les nouvelles sur mon interprétation
sont concentrées principalement sur
l'Ukraine
j'ai vu très peu d'informations et de
nouvelles sur les autres confirmes mais
dans le monde qu'en pensez-vous si vous
êtes d'accord analyse comment
pouvez-vous expliquer cela merci
la balle Raphaël parce que vous avez
découvert l'Europe pourquoi l'Ukraine
parce qu'on nous a dit qu'il y avait des
risques de 3e guerre mondiale aussi
en Europe il y avait des graines
d'escalade là puis on l'a vu quand il y
a eu cet accident avec un missile qui
est tombé sur le sur le territoire
polonais les gens étaient très très
nerveux donc clairement en Europe ils
m'ont est en basé en Europe on sent
qu'il y avait une très grande importance
attachée à ce conflit qui se trouve sur
le continent et puis on le couvert
beaucoup d'un point de vue européen en
étant basé là parce que il y a eu des
conséquences avec cette crise
énergétique qui touche le quotidien des
Européens encore aujourd'hui on le voit
avec les factures qui ont explosé avec
ces stratégies énergétiques
d'approvisionnement conduit revoir les
pays donc ça s'invite dans le quotidien
des gens est clairement du point de vue
européen ça s'est imposé comme un
conflit majeur après est-ce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a énormément d'autres
conflits dans le monde oui est-ce qu'on
devrait le raccorder aussi de
l'importance oui tout à fait je pense
que tous mes collègues sont en accord
avec le fait et qu'il y a des que des
choix qui sont faits mais que
effectivement d'autres conflits
devraient être couverts
en fait moi je vous dirai que il y a
même des répercussions en fait sur
l'ensemble de la planète moi ce que je
vois en Asie c'est que c'est le conflit
qui a le plus d'impact sur ce qui va se
passer en Asie avec l'alignement de la
Chine vers la Russie et on se dirige de
plus en plus vers deux philosophies donc
la Chine la Russie qui conteste le
modèle donc c'est probablement pour ça
et les ramifications à long terme qu'on
se concentre davantage sur ce conflit là
mais on aimerait tous couvrir les autres
conflits
Frédéric
je pense que c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
couvert c'est des choix qui ont été
faits qui sont historiaux mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de conflits
qu'on n'a pas couvert et que toutes les
caméras étaient braquées sur l'Ukraine
alors qu'il y a d'autres conflits donc
ça c'est vrai que c'est peut-être un mec
ou pas qu'on peut faire
on aimerait l'analyse de Me se toucher à
tes bottes
alors écoutez il y a une question
enregistrée on a reçu on a tourné
quelques questions du public alors on
écoute madame Randa à Gazal qui est une
réfugiée
ukrainienne depuis
un peu plus de 10 ans
[Musique]
ça fait après à peu près un an que la
gare a commencé comment assurer que le
monde n'oublie pas et son attention
reste à la tragédie qui les Ukrainiennes
vit chaque jour
mais on aura tout à l'heure une réfugiée
iranienne qui elle quitté l'Iran
alors pour vous comment on fait en sorte
que le conflit ukrainien ne soit pas
oublié c'est c'est un défi parce que je
pense que ça rejoint un peu la question
de Monsieur Touchet
il y a effectivement un effet de
projecteur qui sont braqués sur un seul
et même conflit et une attention énorme
généralement ça suscite beaucoup
d'émotions y compris chez les
spectateurs chez les citoyens dans les
pays comme ici au Canada au départ après
comme pour les soldats qui sont sur le
terrain c'est une guerre d'usure c'est
une guerre d'attrition on lance tout ce
qu'on a c'est un peu le même
comportement qu'on a parfois dans les
médias on y jette tout ce qu'on a nos
ressources jusqu'à ce qu'on en manque et
puis l'intérêt se détourne comme ça
aussi ça reflète un peu la situation sur
le terrain au niveau des combats en
Ukraine je n'ai pas la clé pour
maintenir sur l'intérêt sur ce conflit
là mais tente aussi tenter aussi
longtemps je pense qu'il y aura
un enjeu géopolitique international la
tension ne va pas se détourner
complètement mais comment maintenir
l'intérêt le président de la population
ukrainienne ont été essentielles pour
attirer l'attention du monde entier est
l'aide du monde entier sur ce conflit là
si lui ne ment tous de souffle je pense
que les chances sont bonnes pour qu'on
continue de s'intéresser à ce conflit il
a même participé par vidéo conférence à
la cérémonie de remise des prix cinéma
de la télé cette semaine le Golden glow
mais presque tous les jours il fait des
déclarations en vidéo mais justement
présentons et Poutine des images vous
les avez vous vous êtes retrouvés dans
la même pièce que lui vous avez posé des
questions à l'un ou à l'autre alors on
vous voit qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour votre métier l'influence que ça a
sur l'exercice du métier que de parce
que
whisky c'est le leader improbable d'une
guerre Poutine c'est l'insondable moi
c'est drôle moi j'ai
c'est moi avec Zelenski deux semaines
avant son élection
c'est pas le même homme il a pris un
coup de vieux a rencontré quatre ans
plus tard je me rappelle la première
question que je lui avais posé je lui
avais on était sur le plateau de
tournage de sa dernière émission
du mot les serviteurs du peuple il nous
avait reçu on avait un accès incroyable
et je lui avais demandé vous êtes un
grand acteur pourquoi vous voulez être
président de l'Ukraine il y avait un
ours là
ça arrive il était très habile en
communication mais ça a rien à voir avec
l'homme mais moi ça me donne ça me
permet comme correspondant dans ce coin
du monde là de voir l'évolution et
priorités d'un gouvernement et dans le
cas de l'Ukraine la Russie le but de
Monsieur Zelinski à l'époque c'était de
se rapprocher de la dernière Poutine et
d'essayer de s'entendre avec le dire
parce que et vous allez inscrits on
parle de projet dans un instant pour
vous allez inscrire à quoi ça son
leadership ou sa façon d'être chef de
guerre d'une certaine manière peut
affecter votre travail parce que les
Ukrainiens appuient ce qu'il y a pas de
division dans ce pays-là à moins qu'on
se trompe c'est à dire qu'il y a pas une
unité non plus derrière lui je pense que
les Ukrainiens sont rallier derrière le
chef de guerre et les Ukrainiens ont
compris qu'il était un chef de guerre
utile efficace il est resté au pays
alors qu'on lui offrait de prendre la
fuite tout le monde en a été très fier
et les Ukrainiens reconnaissent que
voilà du meilleur zenenski est allé
chercher beaucoup d'aide sur la scène
internationale ils gardent le conflit en
vie par tous les moyens c'est quelqu'un
qui vient du milieu des As d'un acteur
alors il sait s'adresser à différents
publics il est très habile pour mon
travail à moi ça n'influence pas grand
chose je vous dirais sauf que la
rencontre de gens sur le terrain par
contre qui continue d'être inspiré par
lui d'être derrière lui là
sauf que les Ukrainiens peuvent se
montrer à ces critiques du président
mais pour l'instant je pense que tout le
monde se dit c'est pas le moment ils ont
un problème plus sérieux plus important
à régler et jusqu'à ce que il puisse
reprocher avant de dormir ici ça gestion
du conflit ils vont ils vont attendre un
peu plus tard avant de lancer ses
critiques là sur la place publique et je
reviens à Poutine parce que vous lui
avez posé une question l'année dernière
mais il parlait d'opération spéciale
c'est dans le choix des mots vous avez
été banni on en reparlera tout à l'heure
mais l'importance de Poutine enfin
l'effet l'importance de Poutine vous
savez cette conférence de presse c'était
à Genève avec Joe Biden c'est en pleine
covid et je m'en veux à refaire je lui
poserai une autre question que je
l'avais proposé des regrets
les gens veulent savoir comment
fonctionne en tant que journaliste c'est
une leçon de journaliste parce que il
avait retiré ses troupes la frontière de
l'Ukraine après avoir obtenu un sommet
ce sommet là avec Joe Biden
il y a presque aucune question sur
l'Ukraine durant cette conférence de
presse c'était sur naval mais sur les
droits de la personne il a envoyé paître
tous les journalistes et quand ça a été
mon tour à la toute fin il m'a pointé du
doigt toutes les questions avaient été
posées moi je vais demander pourquoi il
est pas capable de se de s'entendre avec
Joe Biden il m'avait dit à l'époque je
l'ai réécoutais dit parce qu'on a des
c'est une question de ma fille en fait
de 9 ans qu'on a des jouets très
dangereux et qu'on essaie de tout faire
pour éviter de les utiliser
avec le recul je formulerais ma question
autrement mais la réponse était locante
mais
c'est important d'avoir un contact avec
les chefs et le choix des mots
j'aimerais ça vous entendre rapidement
là-dessus quand on couvre une situation
aussi critique le choix des mots ça
compte opération spéciale guerre ou même
dans toutes les situations quand même
non non
c'est une guerre illégale c'est une
opération militaire c'est quoi c'est
l'agresseur est-ce que ça ça boutique
quand vous écrivez vos reportage ou pas
mais moi les Ukrainiens nous rapproche
tout le temps qu'on parle de la guerre
en Ukraine mais l'invasion à grande
échelle ils veulent qu'on le précise et
nous corrige parce que la guerre il la
vive peut-être qu'à Kiev ils étaient
très loin de ça mais dans l'est de lui
dans la guerre elle a fait des dizaines
de milliers de morts donc oui le choix
des mots est important
après la pause d'une autre année
violente aussi aux Etats-Unis comment
ouvrir des pays aussi polarisés aux
prises avec des guerres parfois et des
logiques
[Musique]
c'est dans un climat tendu que se
déroule ces élections de mi-mandat
[Musique]
son objectif était clair et précis tu es
le plus grand nombre de personnes noires
possibles
les Américains lancent un véritable cri
du cœur pour mettre un terme à toutes
ses fusillades dans les secondes notre
tuerie insensée on est devant cette
école qui était le théâtre de cet
horrible tragédies
pourquoi un jeune homme décide de
s'équiper et abattre des enfants
[Musique]
de ramendoza une grand-maman qui ne
pourra plus jamais tenir sa petite fille
de 10 ans dans ses bras il y a pas pire
cauchemar au fond que de perdre un
enfant c'est tous les États-Unis donc
société violente divisée polarisée je
m'adresse à vous Frédéric parce que vous
étiez à auvaldé une autre fusillade en
des centaines par année des milliers de
morts à chaque année comment ça vous
marque comment
réentendre le son de Madame Mendoza que
j'avais en face de moi exposé les
questions ça à chaque fois ça me chavait
en fait ça me chavir parce que j'en ai
fait des fusillades mais c'est sûr que
je veux pas quand il y a des enfants qui
sont impliqués quand il y a un homme qui
s'équipe avec une arme fusible militaire
là qui littéralement détruit ses enfants
avec Abou portant où on est même plus
capable de d'identifier le corps lors de
l'autopsie
c'est toujours épouvantable et on dit à
chaque fois
qu'en 2012 il y a eu ceci il y a eu ça
ça va changer et ça change rien donc
c'est sûr que là on se dit à chaque fois
c'est il faut armer davantage dans les
écoles la solution c'est évidemment
encore plus d'accessibilité aux armes
alors qu'en fait c'est terrible il y a
400 millions d'armes a fait aux
États-Unis je veux dire il y en a plus
que de la population mais c'est sûr que
quand je couvre ce genre d'événements je
peux pas faire abstraction de ma
situation personnelle aussi je veux dire
je vis aux États-Unis j'ai deux jeunes
enfants qui vont évidemment dans une
école en sans l'Américain et quand je
pars comme ça je le pose toujours la
question comment je vais leur expliquer
que je m'en vais couvrir une fusillade
ou un homme un jeune homme de moins de
20 ans a décidé d'aller tuer des enfants
qui ont le même âge que le mien et ça
c'est toujours très difficile parce que
je veux dire ça nous replonge dans cette
possibilité que aussi que ça arrive un
coup de téléphone à l'école bon il y a
une situation de confinement parce que
il y a un homme qui est armé jusqu'aux
dents donc c'est sûr que ça nous touche
pleinement
et mais en même temps c'est une société
qui est quand même très violente les
États-Unis
il y a 200 ans c'était la guerre civile
c'était ça revient toujours cet aspect
de l'arme à feu qui est vraiment au-delà
oui exactement qu'est-ce qu'on faisait
ses enfants quand on rentre de reportage
d'abord ce qu'ils voient évidemment vous
reportage au Canada et son processus
est-ce que il voit vous rapporter je
peux leur montrer mais en même temps je
veux aussi épargner parce que à ce
moment-là ça peut ça peut aussi les les
insécurités davantage parce que dans le
fond quand on va en Ukraine ou dans des
pays qui sont en conflit qui sont en
guerre il y a une prévisibilité que bon
notre métier nous amène dans des
situations où on peut être victime d'un
lycée mais aux États-Unis il y a cette
imprévisibilité qui nous suit tout le
temps parce que on peut aller à
l'épicerie on peut aller à l'école on
peut aller n'importe où et on peut faire
les frais d'une balle perdue il y a des
fusillades où c'est que vous êtes là
pourquoi vous acceptez d'y aller mais
parce que ça fait partie du travail
peut-être que puis c'est important de
rendre compte de ça aussi de
sensibiliser les gens et parce que je
veux dire au on est quand même
relativement épargné par ce genre de
phénomène et pouvant table de ces
fusillades qui sont terribles plus que
deux par jour des fusillades de masses
où on a au moins quatre personnes qui
sont soit blessés ou tuer si on exprime
même les le ou les tirs il y a pas aussi
un risque de de banalisation de toute
cette violence évidemment évidemment
c'est sûr que ça fait partie du
quotidien
comment vous la vivez cette situation là
c'est un peu la même chose dans les
écoles ils font des exercices de se
cacher sous l'étape si jamais il y a un
tireur fou qui rentre dans une dans une
classe moi j'ai mon fils aussi avec moi
et 10 jours avant ou valdé c'était à
bafouleau il y a une tuerie dans un
dépanneur et c'était des personnes
afro-américaines et c'était prémédité le
tireur est arrivé avec son son physique
d'assaut et ce qui est terrible aux
États-Unis en fait c'est j'ai couvert
aussi des conflits il y a la fin de la
guerre aux États-Unis c'est ça ne finit
pas c'est tous les jours et le paradoxe
c'est après une fusillade bah les gens
il y a une montée de les gens vont
acheter des armes pour se protéger des
prochaines fusils donc il y a pas de et
le débat qui a eu au Congrès on se pose
la question est-ce que quelqu'un qui a
des antécédents judiciaires ou
psychologiques devraient porter une arme
ou pas est-ce qu'on devrait vendre une
arme à une personne dangereuse donc il
se pose des questions pour nous ça nous
semble tellement évident mais aux
États-Unis c'est pas évident et c'est ça
qui est très frustrant donc quand on
voit des gens qui manifestent j'ai
découvert beaucoup de manifestations
la plupart des gens sont contre les
armes surtout après ou valider Frédéric
a couvert il y a eu des enfants vers les
filles il y en a énormément mais il y a
ce sentiment d'impuissance et puis moi
je me souviendrai toujours de cette
pancarte d'une dame qui tenait une
pancarte qui disait le gouvernement vous
contrôlez mon utérus mais il veut pas
contrôler la vente d'armes et il y a
c'est un pays un paradoxe un pays plein
de paradoxes et c'est vrai que c'est les
gens enfin bafolo c'était quand même
assez assez triste quoi puisque c'était
quand même c'était les victimes avaient
de 10 à 86 ans imaginer une femme de 86
ans ma de faire ses courses dans un
quartier assez pauvre de bafelo dans un
dépanneur ou franchement qui a été
ouvert et à peine 20 ans et là il y a un
tireur fou qui vient qui est du piqué
épargne les personnes blanches
et qui a une caméra sur lui qui filme la
fusillade c'est c'est extrêmement parce
que je peux me permettre la question de
la connaissez la question je la connais
pas
le fait d'être vous-même une femme noire
couvrant des événements comme ça
confrontés au racisme et la violence
qu'il le racisme engendre est-ce que ça
ça change quelque chose je pense que
c'est je pense qu'aux États-Unis c'est
une réalité quotidienne on l'a vu avec
dans notre chambre il y a des mouvements
d'extrême droite il y a une espèce de
radicalisation qui qui se fait aux
États-Unis par les médias aussi on parle
sans cesse de grand remplacement donc un
jeune de 10 celui qui était à Bafou il
avait 18 ans il est dans son sous-sol il
se radicalise tout seul et c'est un peu
le résultat de ça il y a pas vraiment de
donc
moi je couvre ça comme n'importe quel
conflit que j'ai couvert ou fusillade
mais c'est sûr qu'en parlant aux
Afro-Américains ils se sont beaucoup
confiés à moi et c'est vrai qu'il me
disait c'est nous en plus as-tu vu la
façon dont il s'est fait arrêter et tu
sais il s'est fait arrêter les menottes
alors qu'on pensait évidemment à l'image
de Josh float qui s'est fait arrêter
avec qui en est mort d'ailleurs avec un
genou sur le coup donc c'est vrai qu'il
y a une injustice qui est aussi
institutionnalisée il y a un racisme
institutionnalisé aux États-Unis et les
Afro-Américains en sont conscients et
puis nous comme journaliste on en était
moins quand on a vu l'arrestation de cet
homme après qu'il ait tué 10 personnes
et là d'ailleurs il va recevoir sa peine
le 15 février c'est sûr qu'il y a
beaucoup de colère
alors c'est quand même un fardeau pour
vous
pour tout le monde j'espère
une question de Monsieur Dubé
bienvenue merci
donc est-ce essentielle de donner la
parole aux gens qui ont des propos
considérés extrêmes par plusieurs
notamment aux États-Unis puis en
psychiatrie à l'avortement ou aux armes
à feu ou racisme par exemple
je vous lance la question Frédéric parce
que dans le montage qu'on a vu en début
de segments d'émission avec quelques
extraits très brefs de gens qui tiennent
des propos extrêmes mais je pense
c'était essentiel justement qu'on entend
de ces gens-là parce que si on ne va pas
les voir si on essaie pas de comprendre
aussi ce qui est ce qui les anime je
pense qu'on manque complètement le
bateau au niveau d'une couverture parce
que c'est une une proportion assez
importante de la population américaine
qui pense qu'effectivement le racisme ce
n'est pas grave l'avortement de toute
façon c'est pas notre problème et les
armes à feu ils font l'avoir davantage
parce que ça prend toujours ça en prend
plus pour se défendre je pense que ce
qui est important de noter c'est que
évidemment toute cette espèce de c'est
surtout des extrémistes aussi et on est
quand même dans un dans l'univers de la
la Poste vérité là et là on a cette
polarisation qui qui vraiment anime ces
gens là et notre rôle à nous évidemment
de refléter les différentes pensées mais
ultimement le Christ si on me dit que il
y a mille soleil dehors et l'autre il me
dit il pleut des cordes moi mon rôle
c'est de dire de sortir par la fenêtre
de regarder je m'excuse il pleut il y a
pas de soleil donc il faut quand même
remettre ça en perspective malgré tout
tout en en prenant le pou quand même de
ces gens-là on n'est pas là pour leur
faire changer d'opinion c'est pas
possible ils sont comme ça il y a
parfois de doctrinement parfois c'est
c'est des mouvements très bien organisés
mais nous en tant que journaliste
comment ils vous voient ces gens là
parce qu'on connaît la haine des médias
notamment Alexa comment il vous voit
c'est sûr que depuis 2016 quand Donald
Trump a pris le pouvoir c'est sûr que ça
a beaucoup changé parce que oui a ouvert
les vannes justement de on peut dire
n'importe quoi on peut faire n'importe
quoi fake news milliards vous êtes
l'ennemi du peuple c'est sûr que nous
quand on va sur le terrain dès qu'il
voit une caméra à your fake news etc
donc c'est sûr qu'on l'entend tout le
temps mais en même temps je veux dire on
fait notre travail on dit mais non on
peut vous parler on va vous écouter mais
arrêtez de partir du principe on va
forcément mentir oui non c'est ça c'est
très il y a vraiment une radicalisation
nous quand on fait par exemple des
sujets sur l'avortement ou s'il y a la
religion aussi qui entre en compte et
souvent c'est extrêmement émotif donc tu
peux pas vraiment raisonner mais je
pense que le public pour nous je pense
dans nos reportage on est obligé
d'équilibrer les opinions faut montrer
toutes les opinions et le plus le public
est capable de se faire sa propre
opinion je sais qu'une fois on a couvert
justement un rassemblement qui on a dit
CBC on est de CBC puis quelqu'un dit Oh
great vous êtes de Christine brookly
pourquoi
on l'a pas trop on n'a rien dit on a dit
[Rires]
aussi donc il y a plus il y a quand même
de l'idéologie là-dedans mais ce qui se
vit aux États-Unis la montée du
populisme ça a changé la façon de
travailler la pose vérité tout ça mais
ça ça c'est contagieux comment ça se vit
quand vous êtes sur le terrain
Raphaël ben moi j'ai été aux États-Unis
il y a quelques années pendant justement
la présidence de Donald Trump donc j'ai
découvert plusieurs de ces
rassemblements je dois dire aussi que
quand même quand on est canadien on a un
accès simple représentant de la question
Broadcasting Corporation on a un accès
qui est assez bon les gens sont ouverts
à nous parler parce que cette
polarisation elle est beaucoup au niveau
des médias américains une grande un des
médias américains c'est peut-être un peu
moins le cas à l'endroit des médias
canadiens ça c'est un avantage dont on
dispose sur le terrain maintenant je
suis en Europe et on voit cette
polarisation qui existe aussi dans les
sociétés européennes
par exemple faire des reportages dans le
cadre d'élection en Hongrie la
réélection de Victor Hormann et le
sentiment que j'avais c'était un peu de
me retrouver dans un rassemblement de
Donald Trump quand on couvrait les
partisans de Victor urban il y avait
beaucoup de similitudes dans le titre de
propos qu'on entendait et là d'ailleurs
ça m'a pas été très favorable d'être
représentant d'un média canadien parce
que quelqu'un ne met pas du tout le
Canada et ses politiques il est venu
clairement me le dire donc ça c'est un
peu différent des États-Unis mais on
voit cette division là puis on la voit
ailleurs en Europe par exemple prenez le
Royaume-Uni ou le débat sur le brexit il
est toujours présent et il divise
beaucoup la société c'est de brigades le
regret du brexit
un peu pour certains mais quand on parle
de polarisation
qui sont parfois des discussions de de
sourd de gens qui ne s'entendent pas sur
cette question du brexit et ça ça
rappelle aussi ce qu'on voit aux
États-Unis entre démocrates et
républicains l'équilibre de la parole
certainement parce que si on ne parle
pas aux gens qui appuient le brexit
comment on peut voir venir ce mouvement
qui finalement s'est concrétisé c'est
essentiel je pense
de la polarisation à l'échelle de la
planète est vraiment incroyable et j'ai
découvert un sujet qui est absolument
rien à voir avec la situation aux
États-Unis ou en Europe j'ai été sur une
petite île un archipel tout près de de
la Chine qui appartient sur un
territoire taïwanais on voulait
démontrer que c'est pas blanc ou noir
c'est tension là entre la Chine et
Taïwan qui il y a des gens qui ont des
attachements à la chaîne même s'ils sont
taïwanais et il y a des gens qui ont vu
le reportage et on est dans cet esprit
là de polarisation ou tout doit être
d'un côté ou l'autre et on me reprochait
d'avoir été trop nuancé d'avoir
admis qui en fait il y a plus qu'une
situation plus qu'une vérité dans ce
cas-là donc c'est vraiment l'état
d'esprit dans lequel on est de toute
façon générale et les gens qui me le
disaient étaient des gens qui venaient
d'ici du Canada qui avait vu le
reportage très bien alors
tout le monde a un peu tout dit je
dirais-je conclurai simplement en
rappelant que notre rôle chez nous c'est
jamais de juger les gens à qui on parle
mais de les écouter pour pouvoir
refléter ces idées parce qu'elles
existent ça ne sert à rien de se mettre
la tête dans le sable et je pense qu'on
offre un portrait beaucoup plus complet
de ce qui se passe autour de nous quand
on donne la parole à tout le monde sans
nécessairement cautionner c'est pas ce
que l'on fait on n'a pas à dire que
c'est bien ou pas mais il faut permettre
à ces idées là d'être transmise aussi on
peut pas vivre en vase clos avec des
gens qui nous ressemblent en tout point
ils pensent comme nous et parce qu'on
les diffuse qu'on est d'accord ça c'est
clair et dans le cas de la Russie c'est
vous savez Anne-Marie quand la guerre
s'est déclenchée regardez quelqu'un dans
les yeux qui nous dit tant mieux on va
aller finalement se débarrasser des
nazis en Ukraine
c'est dur à entendre on connaît les
vérités mais on n'est pas là pour juger
on a eu pour écouter c'est important de
montrer que ces gens-là existe parce que
dans le cas de la Russie si on vit dans
un monde de propagande ou c'est pas une
exception mais plutôt la règle ça fait
partie de la réalité du pays concours
ici on ne comprend pas les gens qui nous
entourent on peut pas faire comme il
faut si je peux rajouter juste une
petite chose aux États-Unis ce qui est
très dur aussi c'est les réseaux de
télévision c'est Fox News contre CNN et
quand vous écoutez Fox News qui répètent
tout le temps la même chose il parle du
Grand remplacement que les États-Unis
vont être envahis par des migrants donc
les gens finissent par se radicaliser et
il y a énormément de mensonges qui sont
diffusés à la télévision et ça
radicalise une partie de la population
et je pense que il y a un rôle des
médias aussi sur sur toutes ces
pratiques de la population de la seule
fois où finalement on disait qu'on était
canadien puis on nous aimait bien si il
me dit vous avez vos camionneurs
Canadiens bravo
mais abandonné la question je la
laissais un peu plus tôt est-ce que les
gens vous perçoivent comme des méchants
socialistes communistes comme ou le
prolongement de la politique canadienne
Frédéric oui évidemment à travers les
réseaux sociaux à travers les énormes
commentaires qu'on reçoit souvent oui
énormément et puis
oui mais c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on parlait l'exportation
justement de la polarisation et c'est
comme si les les personnes qui qui nous
suivent et décident de nous envoyer des
e-mails de bêtises des des messages sur
les réseaux sociaux on regarde un peu et
c'est exactement comme si c'était
perroquet de ce qu'on entend aux
États-Unis ceux qui écoutent Tucker
Carlson sur Fox News donc c'est toujours
un peu les mêmes termes qui reviennent
et qui oui c'est ça et donc on retrouve
partout donc c'est c'est ça qui est
quand même incroyable parfois inquiétant
parce que parfois c'est assez violent
aussi et et donc je veux dire l'idée
derrière ça c'est de ne pas engager
parce qu'encore une fois on n'est pas là
pour
on est convaincre de quoi que ce soit je
veux dire ces gens là en général ne
changent pas d'idées et continue leur
leur chemin vers justement ce qui pense
être la vérité et au fur et à mesure de
répéter leurs mensonges des fois où les
faussetés quelque part qui colleportent
ils pensent que ça devient une vérité
que les gens les vont les croire ils
vont les suivre davantage ça révèle
l'importance de couvrir ces pays-là ces
situations là on l'a vu correctement
avec le Brésil il est important de
rapporter ce qui se passe là-bas alors
on va poursuivre après la pause il rend
Afghanistan avortement va y revenir aux
États-Unis des reculs pour les femmes
cette année il faut y revenir à tout de
suite rester avec nous cette émission
spéciale avec nos correspondants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas d'âge minimal légal pour le
mariage en Afghanistan il va donc offrir
en mariage
Habiba 7 ans
sa fille opéra fils de paiement
[Musique]
les femmes mariées doivent obtenir le
consentement de leur conjoint afin
d'avoir accès à l'avortement
libre n'interdire le droit à
l'avortement
l'accès à l'avortement qui est en jeu
mêlé des
femmes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
répression en Iran on voit ça tous les
jours recule des droits des femmes en
Afghanistan on voit ça aussi tous les
jours recule de la fortement aux
États-Unis et vraiment une année
dramatique pour les femmes un peu
partout dans le monde Marie-Ève je
commence avec vous parce que vous avez
réalisé une histoire presque canadienne
dans le fond avec l'Afghanistan vous
avez réalisé le dernier reportage qui
était possible de faire pourquoi c'est
le dernier reportage donc on va voir un
écran dans un instant mais pourquoi le
reportage qu'on a vu sur
le dernier reportage qu'on a pu faire en
Afghanistan de mon côté parce qu'à la
suite de la diffusion de ces reportages
là
mon oncle mais aussi le nom de mon
caméraman Sergio Santos se sont
retrouvés sur une liste qu'on a reçu par
des contacts en Afghanistan mais qui
viendraient des services de
renseignement des talibans c'est
essentiellement une liste de gens à
arrêter et assassiner donc dans le
contexte
alors c'est désespérant pour vous pour
pouvoir y retourner et continuer de
couvrir la situation on va regarder un
extrait ma foi éprouvant de ce que vous
avez tourné en Afghanistan en écoute
elle le sait et elle me dit qu'elle ne
veut pas y aller et les trop petits mais
je n'ai pas le choix je dois le faire tu
vois
quand il viendront pour ma fille je leur
donnerai qu'elle le veuille ou pas à 8
ans c'est impossible qu'elle en soit
heureuse elle lui dira qu'elle part
vivre chez un oncle qu'elle n'a jamais
rencontré ce qui lui arrivera après ne
sera plus de son ressort dit-elle
racontez-nous et comment ne pas être
éprouvé quand on entend des choses
pareilles c'est prouvant évidemment
surtout je sais pas si c'est surtout
mais enfin j'ai passé les 20 dernières
années à visiter le pays régulièrement
on a vu des périodes beaucoup plus
prometteuses que ce qu'on voit
maintenant en Afghanistan c'est comme si
c'était la consécration de l'échec d'une
politique du Canada mais de toute la
communauté internationale et petit à
petit depuis le retour au pouvoir des
talibans c'est la deuxième fois que je
retourne en Afghanistan en ce moment là
c'était en juin on a vu le droit des
femmes disparaissait fruité petit à
petit on leur a enlevé le droit d'aller
à l'école secondaire pour les filles
promettant qu'on allait ramener la
permission d'y aller quand on aurait
fait des accommodements ensuite on est
revenu sur cette parole là on a laissé
les filles qui avaient déjà fait leurs
études secondaires à la l'université
mais dans des conditions excessivement
difficiles et puis là il y a moins d'un
mois à peine on leur retire ce droit là
et c'est toutes ces femmes qu'on a
croisées qui ont été des femmes à une
époque
ambitieuse heureuse qui se voyait avec
un avenir et qui aujourd'hui c'était
dans un autre portage mais qui nous dit
on souffre de dépression à tout le monde
les femmes organes sont déprimées parce
qu'elles ne voient aucune porte de
sortie mais surtout aucun espoir et pour
nous maintenant c'est excessivement
difficile de pouvoir leur donner de
nouveau une parole qu'elles veulent
conserver mais votre rôle à vous comme
journaliste c'est témoigner de ça mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a de vous dire au Père
maintenant on peut pas vendre votre
fille ça a pas de bon sang on peut pas
laisser marier avec un homme de 50 ans
comme femme occidentale bien sûr que
c'est choquant mais sur le moment c'est
pas la réaction qui me vient à moi moi
je fais pas je pense que si on fait ce
métier là c'est qu'on a beaucoup
d'empathie pour les gens avoir de
l'empathie ça ne veut pas dire qu'on est
d'accord avec les gestes qui posent mais
je peux pas moi me mettre
à la place de ces familles là je n'ai
jamais connu la réalité
et je ne peux même pas l'imaginer en
fait pas plus la sienne à lui que celle
de cette mère qui dit qu'elle va pas
juste pas annoncer à sa fille que c'est
ce qui l'attend parce qu'elle peut rien
y changer de toute façon alors aussi
bien attendre qu'elle soit partie chez
son mari dans la famille dans la
belle-famille pour qu'elle apprenne la
vérité c'est sûr qu'on regarde ces
petits après qui sourient qui jouent
complètement inconsciente qui s'amuse de
la présence d'étrangers qui sont dans
l'attente de leurs parents qui veulent
nous montrer les dessins qu'ils ont fait
ça ça crève le coeur mais en même temps
à ses parents là qui acceptent de me
raconter là qui savent très bien que ce
qu'ils font ne se fait pas difficile
l'accès
étonnamment ces gens-là se confient de
façon assez généreuse je vous dirais
parce qu'on s'envoyeur des fois bien sûr
parce qu'on va voir les gens
dans des situations excessivement
difficiles cet homme qui qu'on voit dans
le reportage et qui dit elle-même elle
veut rester avec moi mais je n'ai pas
d'autre choix c'est un homme qui avait
été policier qui avait été formé par la
coalition internationale dans le Canada
qui avait eu un emploi au gouvernement
donc il y avait une certaine fierté
aussi qui travaillait pour son pays et
qui a tout perdu
on a une question aussi de
Louis-Philippe Pelletier que je partage
avec vous ça vous concerne tous
direz-vous que c'est un aspect difficile
de votre travail que de ne pas pouvoir
soulager davantage la misère que vous
rencontrez c'est dans la foulée de ce
qu'elle vient de
je pense que quelque chose d'important
au début de l'émission c'est qu'on n'est
pas là pour juger mais oui on se sent de
un voyage et très impuissant mais c'est
pas juste dans la misère qu'on voit dans
les cultures dans lesquelles on vit nous
en tant que famille on déménage en
Russie on a nos valeurs avec les lois
canadiennes qu'on connaît les droits et
la protection des femmes qui nous est
familières on arrive en Russie où la
violence conjugale n'est pas criminalisé
a été décriminalisée donc oui on fait
des reportages nous on parle aux
victimes on a beaucoup d'empathie
mais c'est le jour où on en témoigne en
fait que ça nous frappe et moi je me
rappellerai toujours mon expérience en
Russie j'ai fait plusieurs sujets sur la
violence conjugale j'ai parlé à des
femmes j'ai senti leurs douleurs mais le
jour où j'étais moi en vacances à Sotchi
dans le sud de la Russie j'étais allongé
en maillot à la piscine et j'ai vu une
femme sorcière sur un balcon hurlé parce
que son mari la bataille et personne
Anne-Marie autour de moi bougeait moi
l'occidental mais pas l'occidental les
femmes russes sont révoltées aussi je
suis allée à la réception qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on fasse faire des
reportages c'est une c'est difficile
c'est les cultures et c'est la réalité
des pays qu'on
a des pays démocratiques comme les
États-Unis où vous avez couvert les
migrants aux frontières il y a aussi une
détresse puis il y a une puissance dont
raconte-nous
au Mexique aller voir parce que on
parlait à provoque des migrants
Ukrainiens qui passaient par le Mexique
pour aller aux États-Unis mais moi
j'étais de l'autre côté de la frontière
dans quartier Juana aller dans un refuge
où on a des centaines de migrants qui
sont entassés là depuis parfois six mois
un an deux ans qui vise dans des
conditions évidemment très précaires et
donc c'est sûr que on est on est
vraiment bouleversé humainement parce
qu'on voit ces gens-là qui ont fui des
situations excessivement difficiles qui
ont eu des menaces de mort ou qui ont
perdu des membres de la famille dans des
affaires de guerre de cartel ou des gens
qui ont été pourchassés au Salvador et
c'est sûr que quand on va dans ce genre
d'endroit là on ne peut qu'être ému
surtout quand vous avez un petit garçon
qui me prend la main un petit garçon de
5 ans et qui dit ah je viens jouer avec
moi j'aimerais ça un jour aller aux
États-Unis là où tu habites puis en même
temps on était impuissant parce qu'on ne
peut rien faire je veux dire ce qu'on
peut faire c'est sensibiliser la
population à ce genre de problématique
là après ça les gens peuvent s'organiser
pour pour justement faire des collègues
de fonds ou essayer de s'impliquer pour
voir si on peut à les adopter etc mais
mais je veux dire mes journalistiquement
c'est difficile on ne peut pas se
mobiliser personnellement on est là pour
rendre pour témoigner dans le fond après
ça des gens font ce qu'ils veulent mais
on a quand même un rôle à jouer dans
cette sensibilisation
éventuellement Philippe
notamment Pologne je pense que vous avez
pu mais
très très trou très tôt dans le conflit
je suis allé dans un orphelinat où il y
avait des orphelins qui étaient déplacés
de Kiev et qui s'en venaient
et c'est sûr que ça vient vous arracher
le coeur parce que ces gens-là ces
jeunes là vivaient des jeunes situations
extrêmement difficile on vient les
déplacer en raison de la guerre et c'est
certain qu'on a envie de les aider mais
le cameraman avec qui j'étais Frédéric
Tremblay avait dans ses valises des
petites bouteilles de sirop d'érable et
puis on changera pas le monde avec ça
mais on va les écouter on va les faire
sourire puis on va leur montrer qu'on a
de l'empathie puis et peut-être qu'on va
changer leur monde le temps d'une
matinée on va leur offrir du sirop
d'érable et le lendemain ils se sont
fait promettre par le chef cuisinier de
l'endroit de manger des crêpes pour la
première fois avec du sirop d'érable
c'est rien pour nous ça mais pour eux ça
a été un moment dont ils vont toujours
se rappeler des fois une conversation
courtoise respectueuse avec les gens ça
peut être un bon moment aussi je pense
Philippe parler de la Pologne quand on
était en Pologne au début de la guerre
j'entends parler français mais dans une
gare où arrivait des des réfugiés et je
vois ce groupe de gens qui venaient du
Congo qui était allé étudier travailler
en Ukraine qui se sont qui se sont
retrouvés au milieu de cette guerre avec
un traitement qui a été discriminatoire
de la part des autorités frontalières de
part et d'autre il y a des reportages
qui ont été faits là-dessus donc ce sont
des gens qui se sont retrouvés au milieu
d'une guerre ont dû traverser sans
ressources ne sachant pas où aller dans
un autre pays qu'il ne connaissait pas
la Pologne et avoir une conversation
avec ces gens-là ça a été un moment où
on a pu dire bah écoutez il y a des
ressources ici et là en dehors de
l'entrevue évidemment on peut peut-être
aiguiller aussi sans nous-mêmes à des
travailleurs humanitaires ce n'est pas
notre rôle mais parfois rediriger les
gens pour leur dire écoutez là il y a
peut-être quelqu'un qui peut vous donner
un coup de main c'est aussi quelque
chose qui est possible puis je pense
qu'on peut pas faire ce métier si on
veut pas changer le monde je pense que
nous à travers les reportages on a envie
justement qui est des réactions qui est
des changements je me suis en Italie en
Haïti juste après le tremblement de
terre et les gens se trouvent dans une
situation extrêmement difficile ou même
au Mexique où il y avait des réfugiés
haïtiens qui ont traversé pendant des
mois et des mois et c'est vrai que comme
journaliste il y a aussi je vous avoue
une frustration quand il y a pas autant
de réactions de la part de la communauté
internationale alors que pour l'Ukraine
il y a eu beaucoup de solidarité mais
pour les migrants qui sont générale à la
frontière des États-Unis même en Europe
il y a vraiment un problème et je pense
qu'on va voir de plus en plus de
migrants dans le monde les réactions
sont quand même différentes et ça c'est
ça c'est très difficile la tentation des
gagner de l'argent de donner des
aliments de
vraiment essayer de sauver
[Rires]
est-ce que on vous demande
Anne-Marie on est humain vous savez dans
les gens je sais pas vous mais les gens
sont tellement généreux avec nous déjà
qui n'ont absolument rien Marie nous
accueille avec du thé avec des biscuits
avec des petits chocolats il trouve le
moyen de nous accueillir comme ça quand
vous voyez dans le reportages à la télé
des scènes où on sert le thé le café
c'est pas c'est pas une mise en scène
c'est parce que les gens nous reçoit
comme ça même dans leur misère nous en
Russie en tout cas c'est c'est une
tradition la même du sucre du lait de la
farine des biscuits s'il y a des enfants
c'est pas c'est pas un échange c'est pas
en échange du témoignage c'est par
courtoisie par compassion ça ne tente
absolument pas la façon dont on
travaille parce que dans le fond de
reconnaissance vous faites un travail
extraordinaire
un idéal journalistique de voir de
rapporter ce qui se passe dans le monde
mais vous vous arrivez puis vous
repartez quand vous repartez là est-ce
que ça continue de vous hanter de dire
ben on les laisse dans leur misère
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait pour eux je vois
qui veut répondre
oui on est on rentre chez eux comme dit
Tamara c'est vrai que c'est les portes
ouvertes c'est une générosité il se
confie à vous et on repart et c'est vrai
qu'on il y a ce sentiment un peu de pas
de voyeurisme mais on les a utilisés un
peu pour nos reportages et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait nous pour eux
quand on part donc ça ça reste quand
même ce sentiment un peu de culpabilité
qu'on retrouve un peu notre luxe entre
guillemets puis qu'on les laisse dans
leur on se console avec nos reportages
mais on sait que leur situation va
peut-être pas nécessairement changer
autre situation extrêmement dramatique
après l'Afghanistan les femmes en langue
des maisons bien sûr les femmes en Iran
alors on a une question de madame
golrock qui a dit qu'on écoute
[Musique]
on ira les journalistes ne font pas
libres les autres médias utilisent les
gens civils pour filmer ce qui se passe
en Iran comme un journaliste comment on
peut couvrir à l'événement qu'on peut
pas être dans le pays en tant que
désiraniens comment nous on peut vous
aider pour mieux couvrir les événements
en Iran
pour vous marier
d'abord avec beaucoup de frustration si
on peut pas y aller et aussi je dois
admettre très mal parce que de voir les
choses de parler avec des gens c'est
essentiel pour vraiment pouvoir faire la
distinction entre la réalité entre la
fiction qui se faire aussi
pour apprécier ce qui est en train de se
passer donc même si on parle avec
beaucoup de gens à distance on a des
contacts sur place on arrive à rejoindre
des gens c'est toujours beaucoup plus
difficile de vérifier mais c'est
difficile aussi d'établir un contact qui
est humain si on n'est pas sur place
dans le cas de l'Iran on a difficilement
le choix puisque les journalistes ne
sont pas libres mais les journalistes
étrangers ne peuvent pas non plus entrer
au pays on est en demande de visa pour
les rendre depuis très longtemps et
c'est toujours très aléatoire l'Iran
décide parfois d'ouvrir les portes
généralement de ne pas les ouvrir et là
avec les manifestations c'est
complètement fermé donc on ne peut pas
le mieux que nous on a pu faire c'est
j'ai parlé avec des gens que je
connaissais au Kurdistan irakiens qui
m'ont dit que certaines IR sortait
d'Iran pour aller des iraniennes
d'origine kurde qui venaient se réfugier
au Kurdistan irakien qui avait rejoint
des milices armées les milices armées
qui sont établis qui font partie d'une
opposition politique mais armée aussi au
régime iranien donc ces femmes-là qui
étaient dans les manifestations quelques
jours auparavant qui ont été arrêtés
torturés ont décidé de quitter le pays
mais quitter le pays nous disait-elle
pour mieux y revenir armés préparer pour
lutter contre ce régime ça c'est une
solution de compromis comment est-ce que
la communauté ici au Canada qui est issu
de ces pays où on n'a pas accès
notamment l'Iran peut nous aider
d'abord en nous permettant peut-être de
rencontrer virtuellement plus de gens
pour multiplier son a toujours besoin
d'avoir plus de sources de pouvoir
parler avec le plus de gens possible ça
nous permet quand même de prendre le
pouls parce qu'il y a une variété
d'opinion mais ça reste que c'est un
défi et c'est c'est arrestation
production parce que dès qu'on vient en
aide ou manifestants
cette femme médecin qui est aussi que
c'est sa vie ces derniers jours parce
qu'elle avait soignée des gens blessées
par les manifestation et les familles
les filles qui subissent aussi beaucoup
de pression c'est une tactique qui est
très employée par les régimes iraniens
pour faire avouer des choses ou pour
s'assurer que les familles dénoncent
leurs enfants qui sont allés manifester
alors c'est des pays où règnent
l'obscurantisme total l'Iran
l'Afghanistan mais même aux États-Unis
il y a eu recul du droit des femmes ça
fait des bas pas juste aux États-Unis
mais ailleurs mais quand même regardons
la situation de l'avortement aux
États-Unis
vous avez couvert vous avez accès à des
situations extrêmement
recul on était homicity et c'était ces
femmes qui allaient se faire avorter qui
est porté presque une cagoule qui se
cachait qui était escorté par des
bénévoles des jeunes des étudiantes en
médecine qui était pas payées qui les
protégés en fait des manifestants devant
qui leur criaient des insanités qu'ils
avaient tuer leur enfant que c'était des
criminels il y avait toute la musique
religieuse qui jouait puis ces jeunes
femmes allaient se faire avorter depuis
cette clinique homicide est fermée donc
il y a vraiment eu un recul et alors on
se parle au Congrès là depuis que les
républicains ont la majorité à la
Chambre des Représentants ils viennent
de discuter de nouvelles lois pour
restreindre l'accès à l'avortement
au-delà de 15 semaines donc c'est un
débat qui est extrêmement tendu beaucoup
de femmes une femme me disait mon Dieu
je me suis battue pour
l'arrêt contre Wade pendant 50 ans on a
manifesté dans les années 70 et là de
voir qu'en 20221 on se retrouve 50 ans
en arrière c'est un recul et on sent
vraiment une émotion et peut-être la
consolation quelque part c'est lors des
élections ça a été un des un des enjeux
extrêmement importants sur lesquels les
femmes ont voté et je pensais pas que ça
allait faire ça je vois m'éloigner la
question de l'avortement mais quand on
aborde des questions là comme celle
évidemment il réagissant on est des vous
êtes des femmes journalistes même est-ce
qu'il faut être féministe est-ce qu'on
est fait est-ce qu'on porte le féminisme
qu'on a ce que c'est est-ce que c'est un
interview puisque c'est des femmes aussi
qui sont contre le choix donc on a on
est on les a interviews de la même façon
je gère les personnes qui étaient
Antilles antichois on les a interviewés
je les ai interviewés il y en a une elle
m'a dit écoutez-moi je me suis fait
avorter j'ai regretté toute ma vie et
c'est pour ça que maintenant je
conseille aux femmes de ne pas se faire
avorter donc on est obligé de leur
donner aussi parce qu'il faut qu'on soit
équilibré dans notre reportage parce que
ça fait partie d'une réalité
on en a beaucoup moi j'ai beaucoup
d'empathie pour pour les gens mais je
partage leur frustration et leurs
douleurs mais non moi je l'approche pas
comme comme féminin
pas féministe ou pas c'est c'est la
femme en moi qui qui révolté du fait
qu'un homme peut tabasser sa femme et à
moi ce qu'elle saigne et qu'elle soit à
moitié morte qu'elle soit pas amenée à
l'hôpital mais l'avortement ici on vient
de payer ou l'avortement et les gars
c'est un acquis alors quand on va oui
des situations
c'est vraiment l'empathie vous savez
j'ai travaillé Ottawa pendant 5 ans
chaque jour en montant sur la colline il
y avait des gens qui manifestaient
contre l'avortement c'est une réalité
qu'on rencontre partout où on va
Philippe
moi justement ce qui s'est passé aux
États-Unis m'a amené à m'intéresser à la
situation qui varie énormément de pays
en pays en Asie et ça m'a amené à
découvrir ces sociétés qui souvent sont
paternalistes en Asie beaucoup plus que
qu'ailleurs par exemple en Europe ou ici
et le l'accès à l'avortement et quand
même beaucoup plus facile la Taïwan qui
est un îlot démocratique en Asie par
contre ça veut pas dire que c'est permis
et qu'on songe avoir cette cette
élargissement là de l'accès ça veut pas
dire que c'est nécessairement plus
accepté le jeune couple que j'ai
rencontré se cachait il avait jamais dit
à leur à leurs parents à leurs amis et
quand ils m'ont dit que de toute façon
s'ils avaient été marié ça aurait été
une grosse discussion parce que le gars
était pas nécessairement pour la fille
oui et qu'on doit avoir l'accord de
l'époux dans le dans le couple pour
obtenir l'avortement sans dit long sur
sur cette situation là et sur
l'influence de la religion dans ces
pays-là aussi mais en Europe c'est aussi
une question d'actualité dans certains
pays c'est un enjeu qui est contemporain
je pense à la Pologne entre autres qu'on
a beaucoup couvert pour d'autres raisons
mais Marie-Eve avait fait un reportage
sur l'accès très très difficile à
l'avortement dans ce pays là et en
Italie ou en couvert les élections
italiennes l'arrivée au pouvoir de
Georgia Meloni la nouvelle Première
ministre mais elle a dû s'expliquer se
défendre non pas sur l'égalité de
l'avortement mais l'accès qui est
compliqué dans certaines régions en
Italie donc on voit que là aussi on
n'est pas aux États-Unis le débat
s'exprime pas de la même manière mais
c'est d'actualité pas dans toutes les
régions l'Europe est variée et complexe
mais c'est une réalité pour certaines
personnes absolument ce que je dirais
c'est qu'à votre question ce que les
États-Unis nous démontre est-ce que ce
qu'on voit ailleurs aussi c'est que on
ne peut jamais dire vraiment que c'est
une question qui est acquise pas même
ici pour l'instant ici c'est légal alors
on est en autre question d'avoir un
Victoria tan bonsoir bienvenue tous la
question que j'aimerais vous poser et
comment assurez-vous un équilibre de
votre santé physique et mentale durant
l'émission et les reportages qui
nécessitent une grande résilience
j'ai des enfants aussi qui nous ramènent
vite à la réalité mais je marche
beaucoup j'essaie de faire du sport
d'écouter de la musique et
c'est difficile de décrocher mais moi
j'arrive à décrocher assez facilement
quand même ma mère et l'esprit
mais c'est vrai que quand on part comme
ça dans les pour couvrir les événements
qui sont rarement joyeux malheureusement
de par la nature de notre métier
c'est sûr que ce qui est important
d'avoir c'est bon on a des familles on a
des enfants etc on a des passions mais
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
quand on revient à la maison c'est en
quelque sorte retrouver c'était ancrage
qui mène en cette réalité là je veux
dire si je reviens le samedi soir très
tard je sais que le lendemain dimanche
matin il y a du soccer pour mon fils qui
joue un match donc et je pense c'est
aussi important pour notre santé mentale
à nous parce que des fois on est
toujours sur une l'adrénaline on est là
et on arrive pas à décrocher
effectivement quand on revient et quand
on est sur le terrain quand on a la
chance de partir en équipe il y a nos
collègues cameraman aussi qui sont non
seulement extraordinaires par le travail
qu'ils font mais qui sont aussi des
complices parfois des confidences assez
extraordinaires aussi et c'est important
d'avoir cette appui là en équipe sur le
terrain le soir quand on va partager un
repas quand on a le temps de le faire
c'est discuter d'autres choses quand
c'est possible aussi ça c'est à mon avis
c'est c'est une grande aide parfois de
ne pas être seul sur le terrain d'avoir
des gens avec qui discuter je trouve que
ça ça donnera à son équipe mais vous
quand vous rentrez à la maison moi quand
je rentre à la maison c'est la famille
aussi là on est dans le changement de
couche
il y a aussi bon
encore une fois la famille Tamara oui
c'est la famille mais je pense qu'il
faut démystifier aussi quelque chose
comme correspondante par exemple en
Russie les gens me demandaient ça mais
comment tu fais comment tu décroches on
transporte quand même une vie pas banale
mais normale de famille dans un autre
pays alors moi quand je rentre la maison
ma fille me demande de lui faire des
tresses et jouer ou non
certaines normalité c'est sûr que quand
on part dans des affectations difficiles
on revient moi mes enfants adorent
m'imiter dans les minutes que j'arrive à
la maison
de voyage puis sur
ça fait partie de n'importe quel
affectation mais c'est vrai que la
famille nous ramène à la réalité à la
réalité et Netflix dans l'avion les
séries les plus légères et les plus
insignifiantes
possiblement et ben voilà tout ça alors
on s'en va à la pause madame messieurs à
la maison on vous a demandé des
questions les publics en studio à la
maison on a reçu plein plein de
questions mais il y a une
téléspectatrice qui a été très
délinquante mais c'est pour le meilleur
elle voulait dire quelque chose à nos
correspondants montrer à quel point
mesdames mess collègues et votre travail
est apprécié on écoute Valérie Martel
bonsoir mon nom est Valérie Martel je
tiens à remercier tous les
correspondants journalistes et cameraman
qui nous offre une information de
qualité fois après fois
à Z avec votre sourire timide radio nous
vous aimons sincèrement toujours
pertinente les analyses éclairantes on
voudrait vous avoir à souper avec nous
pour approfondir encore plus les sujets
chers Tamara que dit ce fut toute une
année nous ne pourrons jamais vous
remercier assez pour tout le travail et
le coeur que vous y mettez Frédéric
merci pour vos analyses sur nos voisins
du sud on se demande souvent comment
vous faites pour dénicher toutes ces
informations
Marie-Eve chaque fois on retient notre
souffle toujours ça accroche un grand
respect pour des humains dans les
régions qui souvent souffrent Philippe
on se souvient de vous quand vous étiez
journaliste à Québec vous souliers ont
bien voyagé depuis merci de relever le
défi de couvrir l'Asie Raphaël quelle
chance vous avez de parcourir l'Europe
comme vous le faites nous avons adoré
votre reportage sur la meute merci à
tous les correspondants nous sommes
privilégiés de recevoir autant
d'informations de qualité en français
nous vous souhaitons le meilleur pour
[Musique]
la désinformation et les cyberattaques
sont courantes partout dans le monde les
Ukrainiens font l'objet d'une campagne
de désinformation sur les réseaux
sociaux la vérité les faits sont des
concepts qui ont disparu du paysage
médiatique du Kremlin c'est la guerre
contre la désinformation qu'on voit en
ce moment pour s'éviter des controverses
le Qatar interdit la prise d'image
presque partout elle ne les syndicats de
sécurité s'interposent
les gens sortent manifester mais c'est
complètement interdit depuis ce matin
de prison parce que c'est un corps
possible pour une journaliste d'être
entendue en Russie c'est difficile
des aides et sa photo tel un criminel
en quelques minutes ils étaient chassés
ou brutalement arrêter il y a beaucoup
de médias indépendants en exiles
le diffuseur public annonce la fermeture
officielle du bureau de Pékin
ici au pays on tient pour acquis que le
droit du public à l'information que la
liberté de presse c'est sacrée c'est
intouchable restons plus d'or mais nous
correspondant eux vont dans des pays où
ils sont confrontés tous les jours à la
désinformation à la propagande à la
censure pendant parlait tout à l'heure à
la répression parfois au risque de leur
vie
Tamara parlons de la fermeture du bureau
de Moscou c'est un fait historique qui
va rester dans les annales traduire
canadiennes c'est tout d'abord pourquoi
le bureau a été fermé la vraie raison ou
la raison du crève
[Rires]
fermeture d'abord ça nous en prévenir en
conférence de presse sous prétexte que
c'était une mesure de représailles pour
la décision du
CRTC ici au Canada de bannir la chaîne
RT qui rachète des qui est un média de
propagande russe pour l'extérieur de la
Russie alors que beaucoup de pays
européens en commençant par avait
bannièreté après le début de la guerre
donc ça c'est la raison qu'ils nous ont
donné la vraie raison
c'est un geste facile pour irriter le
Canada sans grande conséquences je pense
qu'on a vraiment fait les frais d'un peu
de tension accrue entre le Canada et la
Russie il y a presque pas de relation de
haut niveau entre le Canada et la Russie
mais on en a fait les frais parce que ça
a pas d'impact sur la Russie
longtemps pleine guerre il y a des gens
qui meurent mais oui pour 40 plus de 40
ans de tradition journalistique qui à un
moment où faut être en Russie alors on
écoute un extrait de votre reportage
d'adieu
nous avons seulement quelques jours pour
vider le bureau de ses souvenirs et
surtout quitter nos collègues
[Musique]
Anastasia elle était la plus jeune de
notre équipe elle incarne cette
génération toujours optimiste même dans
les moments les plus sombres
Radio-Canada au fil du temps aura été là
pour les hauts et pour les bas
qu'est-ce que ça merci de l'avoir
rappelé ça va certainement se retrouver
dans un musée de la presse ou quelque
part
je sais pas si nous écoute
une affiche sur la porte parce que ça
avait comme pas d'histoire de la
pérennité des de la couverture
journalistique depuis plus de 40 ans et
vous l'avez porté en accéléré en faisant
ce reportage parce qu'on s'est mis à
faire vous nous voyez détruire des trucs
j'aurais peut-être dû l'expliquer dans
le reportage c'est des disques durs et
qui était pas on a tout transféré les
archives à Montréal c'est tout numérisé
mais qu'on voulait qu'on devait détruire
avant de jeter donc oui moi j'ai revu
Céline j'ai revu dans le Maryam était au
bureau de Moscou à l'époque de Michel
Cormier elle était réalisatrice de
terrain donc on a vécu on a vu tellement
de phases de ce grand pays
depuis la chute de l'Union soviétique
les balbutissements de la démocratie on
le revu on l'a vu on l'a vu se refermer
pour en être expulsé et vous savez le
reportage qu'on a vu tout à l'heure où
j'essaie de faire un direct et la police
nous empêche ça c'est mon dernier
reportage officiel en Russie
c'est-à-dire
la première fois que ça m'arrivait en
Russie il y avait ce qu'on appelle
tendrement des babouchkas des
grands-mères qui nous qui nous avec des
gros manteau de fourrure qui nous
suivaient étaient clairement envoyé par
par les autorités et ce métier
physiquement entre nous et le téléphone
on filmait au téléphone on a même pas
osé filmer à la caméra
c'était devenu impossible de faire
il fallait strictement se fier aux
sources du Kremlin qui sont pas toujours
les faits mais juste on n'a pas vu
Alexis dans le reportage qui est mon
grand complice en Russie on le voit ici
dans le décor c'est
le voilà en blanc donc
tout le monde va bien
je mettrais pas d'étiquette mais il est
prêt en ce moment
Elena qu'on a vu et toujours en Russie
elle a trouvé du travail avec les médias
français qui sont encore là Irina qui
était notre administratrice était à la
retraite et la plus jeune Anastasia qui
était notre chercher ceci travail
toujours en Russie c'est toute une
équipe et
derrière la caméra mais mon Dieu alors
on va
entendre une question de du public de
Madame Kabongo et qui va vous concerner
directement parce que vous vous avez pas
fermé un bureau mais j'ai pas pu aller
dans un bureau à Pékin puis vous en
ouvrez un autre madame Kabongo on vous
écoute bonsoir madame Dussault bonsoir à
nos correspondantes et nos
correspondants et merci beaucoup de bien
nous informer merci vraiment alors ma
question est la suivante comment on
décide où on ouvre un bureau de
correspondant à l'étranger est-ce en
fonction de l'influence géopolitique de
la région ou du poids économique du pays
ou encore des intérêts du Canada en jeu
merci alors d'accord toutes ces réponses
de fermer le bureau de Pékin puis là on
a eu une réflexion que c'est quand même
entamée qui a duré quelques mois où
est-ce qu'on veut se positionner parce
qu'on doit continuer de couvrir l'Asie
on veut continuer de couvrir l'Asie
d'autant plus que c'est important en ce
moment avec le rôle croissant de la
Chine l'exportation de son modèle
autoritaire donc on s'est dit est-ce que
c'est où le qui serait le meilleur base
de travail est-ce que c'est le Japon
est-ce que c'est taper il y a des il y a
eu des des restrictions sanitaires qui
nous ont empêché de faire certains choix
mais quand même tapis s'est imposé comme
étant le choix le plus pertinent non
seulement en région des tensions
États-Unis Chine Taïwan mais aussi parce
que
au niveau de la géopolitique mondiale
c'est important le Canada va aller jouer
une part plus importante dans ce marché
là et parce qu'on peut surtout essayer
de couvrir la chaîne à partir de l'oeil
il y a des liens entre les gens typiques
qui qui ont de la famille des amis et
des relations quelconque en Chine parce
que c'est le seul à grande frustration à
partir de maintenant pour Témara pour
moi comment est-ce que on veut refléter
cette situation là dans des pays on n'a
pas le droit d'être et moi j'arrive
j'essaie d'ouvrir un bureau et mon défi
à tous les jours c'est non seulement de
couvrir tapis mais de refléter ce qui se
passe en Chine donc la meilleure façon
qu'on a trouvé c'est qu'on est en tapis
parce que c'est important pour vous
d'être là à cet endroit-là
des taïwanais de penser qu'un jour la
Chine pourra c'est d'autant plus
important parce que oui justement je
revois ce que j'ai vu au début de la
guerre en Ukraine à Taipei le risque
d'invasion il y a 6 millions d'attaques
de désinformation par par jour la Taïwan
donc si on n'est pas là on peut pas
rendre compte de la réalité et essayer
de démêler le faux du vrai mais les
autres facteurs qui jouent il y a
d'autres facteurs certainement puis
ne serait-ce que l'acceptation en tant
que canadien c'est très important on est
très très bien perçu là-bas et même si
c'est extrêmement frustrant comme
journaliste de pas être en Chine c'est
une délivrance de pouvoir faire aussi
son métier de façon libre à Taïwan parce
que ça aurait pas été possible et quand
j'étais préparé à être suivi j'étais
préparé à ce qu'on mette des bâtons dans
les roues que ce soit difficile de faire
j'ai appris le mandarin donc finalement
je peux je peux l'utiliser et je profite
également du baseball taïwanais
un peu à ce qu'on disait c'est une façon
de de faire le vide c'est important
parce que je suis un homme orchestre je
suis mon propre caméraman propre monteur
je suis journaliste j'ai juste une
collègue sur place qui est taïwanaise
donc il faut que je trouve mes propres
façons de réussir à faire le vide donc à
la blague je lance mais c'est quand même
c'est un rôle important dans ma vie
juste pour ajouter un mari pour les
bureaux à l'étranger nous quand on a
Radio-Canada
a contre les critères c'était on
cherchait un pays francophones avec un
aéroport international donc nous on
avait choisi la Côte d'Ivoire pour toute
l'Afrique et un pays stable mais un an
après il y a eu le premier coup d'État
en 40 ans donc c'était peut-être pas le
bon choix mais c'est toujours un risque
on sait jamais si on fait les bons choix
pour ouvrir un bureau c'est pas
nécessairement le poids économique pour
répondre à la question de Madame la
Russie n'est pas une grande puissance
économique bien au contraire mais
géopolitique de plus en plus donc il y a
jamais eu de question de fermer le
bureau de Moscou il était plus pertinent
que jamais et c'est vrai que la mobilité
parce que là bon c'est sûr qu'on est
allé on est à l'étude en train de
chercher mais comment couvrir les Russes
comment couvrir la Russie je pense qu'il
faut être honnête envers nous-mêmes et
envers notre nos téléspectateurs et les
gens qui nous suivent de façon très
fidèle on ne peut pas couvrir ces
pays-là on ne peut plus avoir un
portrait aussi juste parce que c'est pas
parfait mais aussi juste
on l'avait quand on avait des
correspondants en Russie
qui était posée tout à l'heure comment
on fait pour par exemple pour les gens
comment on fait mais c'est très
frustrant de couvrir de l'extérieur
c'est très frustrant on va où il sent
les Russes mais on a une on est des gens
qui s'opposent à la guerre qui fuit on
n'a pas le portrait complet alors madame
Françoise a une question justement dans
le prolongement de ce qu'on vient de se
dire bonsoir bonsoir ça me fait plaisir
puis merci pour votre contribution c'est
absolument magnifique le travail que
vous faites ça dépasse tout ce que
j'avais anticipé ou espérer alors mais
quand
je pense à des pays en guerre tel le
conflit Ukraine Russie comment arriver à
y voir clair justement quand on est pas
là justement en plus comment vérifier
les informations alors que tellement de
fausses nouvelles de propagande et puis
d'intérêt divers en jeu
en
Ukraine on y voit pas toujours clair
c'est sûr que le produit fini qu'on vous
présente est très structuré c'est le
résultat de le fruit de beaucoup de
réflexion beaucoup de prudence aussi je
vous donne un exemple en Ukraine moi
j'étais au mois de septembre et la
dernière semaine l'armée
ukrainienne a commencé à libérer rarki
et nous on va tout de suite on a sauté
dans la camionnette on est allé on a
roulé 12 heures vers Rachid mais on nous
a jamais laissé l'opportunité l'armée
ukrainienne de dire si vous osez
traverser un territoire libéré On vous
retire vos accréditations c'est donc
on nous dit que c'est libéré
on peut pas aller le vérifier donc c'est
jamais noir et blanc sur le terrain d'un
côté comme de l'eau
mais c'est un défi et je sais pas si
Maria on n'y voit pas toujours clair
souvent c'est bien le contraire des
expériences particulières
je pense que la première des façons de
vérifier et de comprendre et d'y voir
clair c'est d'y être on en revient
toujours à cette question là
et on parle beaucoup de propagande dans
la guerre entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
et on parle surtout de la propagande que
les Russes font la désinformation les
mensonges mais en temps de guerre tout
le monde fait de la propagande y compris
les Ukrainiens alors il y a ça il y a un
contrôle qui est assez serré des
territoires où il y a des combats ou qui
sont récemment libérés parfois on arrive
à les contourner mais il y a toujours
cette menace qu'on va nous retirer nos
accréditations si on n'est pas très
obéissant et qu'on s'y rend malgré tout
mais je veux raconter une histoire parce
que parfois y être ça permet de faire
des choses comme quand boucha a été
libéré et là l'accès a été ouvert on a
tous vu ces images d'horreur des corps
qui sont chez la rue et quelques jours
plus tard ça a été je pense que ça a été
un choc pour la majorité de la planète
et en quelque sorte et là je le dis de
façon très cynique mais candide ça a été
très payant pour les Ukrainiens parce
que ça ravivait encore une fois
l'intérêt pour le conflit puis ça a
permis de démontrer à quel point ce que
les soldats russes certains d'entre eux
en tout cas faisaient étaient horribles
et nous on est allé peut-être une
semaine plus tard et on est tombé sur
une scène avec l'armée ukrainienne qui
voulait nous montrer un autre endroit où
on avait déterré ou retrouver des corps
on n'avait pas complètement le contexte
on est arrivé là avec plusieurs
journalistes étrangers et tous les gens
qui étaient dans cette espèce de voyage
organisé
et qui avait une certaine expérience du
terrain et de ce genre de scène ont tous
eu un mouvement de recul en faisant
il y a un malaise avec la scène qu'on
nous présente et on avait aucune façon
de vérifier parce qu'il y avait plus
personne à qui parler il y avait des
corps calcinés c'était spectaculaire ça
faisait des images très choquantes
encore une fois mais qui était presque
organisé dans un certain ordre et je
pense qu'on sait tous majoritairement
dit on touche pas à ces images-là
aujourd'hui parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
vérifier je ne doute pas que les corps
ont été brûlés mais ce qu'ils ont été
déplacés ce qui s'est véritablement là
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé si je peux pas
répondre à ces questions sinon que la
scène devant moi
c'était des acteurs des mises en scène
et tout ça donc oui mais si moi je ne
peux pas affirmer que ça ne l'est pas et
que j'ai pas d'éléments autour de moi
pour me permettre de vérifier même ce
que j'ai devant les yeux je vais pas
m'en servir mais ça c'est des images
après qui sont diffusées par les agences
de presse responsabilité que les gens
peuvent utiliser parce qu'en fait
confiance à ces agences de presse là
mais
il y a pas qu'en zone de guerre que
c'est important d'aller vérifier
justement ce qui circule ce qu'on voit
il y a un exemple qui vient en tête on
est allé on a vu ces images vous savez
quand les rues sont commencé à fuir la
conscription puis il y avait ces images
de la frontière avec la Finlande où on
voyait des kilomètres et des kilomètres
et des kilomètres de voiture ça
circulait sur ce réseau social on allait
faire un reportage là-bas il y avait des
gens qui arrivaient bien sûr il y avait
une histoire à raconter mais
certainement pas la scène qu'on avait vu
il y a parfois beaucoup plus de bouchons
de circulation à Montréal certainement à
Paris qu'à la frontière entre la
Finlande et la Russie à ce moment-là et
c'est important d'y aller et de le
préciser dans le reportage que c'est pas
la situation qui était présentée c'était
certainement pas la situation qu'on
voyait à la frontière par exemple entre
la Russie et la Géorgie pour lequel il y
a d'autres reportages qui ont été faits
et ça si on n'y va pas si on se fie
uniquement aux images qui circulent sur
les réseaux sociaux qui sont parfois
repris à l'antenne mais clairement ça
peut avoir des conséquences sur
l'information qui se promène un peu
partout
vous avez vous êtes au coeur même la
tempête de la désinformation parce que
c'est là qu'on a entendu la première
fois quelques années les mots faits
alternatifs donc vous si votre
environnement quotidien tout à fait oui
on le vit depuis 2016 comme me disait
Frédéric tout à l'heure et en fait il y
a des informations mais il y a les
conséquences de cette désinformation là
et aux États-Unis c'est des informations
là j'ai parlé tout à l'heure du grand
remplacement il y a le leader des
sénateurs démocrate qui a écrit une
lettre à Fox News en disant arrêté de
marteler toujours les mêmes messages sur
les migrants sur les étrangers parce
qu'il y a eu ou sur les personnes
homosexuelles parce qu'il y a eu il y a
eu des tuiles il y a eu des fusillades
il y a eu le Paso il y a une tuerie à
Pittsburg aussi dans une synagogue
ensuite il y a eu bofolo donc ils disent
qu'en fait toute cette désinformation et
toute cette espèce de radicalisation
dans les dans les chaînes comme Fox News
ils ont été vraiment pointés du doigt
par beaucoup de gens ils nous ont écrit
des lettres aux animateurs ils ont écrit
une lettre propriétaire de ces médias en
disant attention vous avez du sang dans
les mains parce que vous vous êtes en
train de d'affirmer des choses à la
télévision et des gens vous croient et
agissent en conséquence donc c'est pas
juste à des informations il y a des
conséquences cette désinformation là qui
fait qui fait peur en fait ça la chose
très difficile à travailler aux
États-Unis c'est extrêmement difficile
c'est bien compliqué on parlait de
comment on essaie de se retrouver
justement comme les informations la
propagande etc je pense que la force
d'un réseau de correspondre du Canada
c'est justement d'aller sur le terrain
et puis voir quels sont les faits mais
là où ça devient plus compliqué c'est
qu'on est dans une atmosphère de
désinformation de mal information et là
on est rendu encore plus loin de façon
permanente et il y a un terme qu'on
entend de plus en plus qui s'appelle le
gaslighting ou dans le fond
ce qui qui invente des histoires comme
depuis deux ans on a un président quand
même qui qui nous raconte que l'élection
a été volée elle était truquée tout le
monde est impliqué là-dedans le FBI etc
mais le problème c'est que les personnes
qui suivent ça et qui croient ça le
répète à satiété à nauséames et à un
moment donné ce que ça fait c'est que ça
met en doute vos propres vos propres
croyances des faits et donc il y a comme
une espèce de de force psychologique non
tu es faux tu mens etc etc donc le gars
ça a été essayé de de vous prouver dans
le fond que vous êtes complètement dans
les faits alternatifs et il y a des gens
évidemment qui sont plus vulnérables par
rapport à ça et à ce moment-là qui entre
dans cette espèce d'univers de mal
information et de désinformation
le mari de Nancy Pelosi pardon qui a été
attaqué chez lui quand même parce que
tous les jours on dit Nancy pélosie
c'est une richissime démocrate on
invente toute une histoire sur elle et
il y a des conséquences en fait donc
c'est vous un Asie parce que
je me suis attardé à sujet là on le vu
hier la désinformation c'est
l'instrumentalisation par le régime
chinois de la désinformation ça sert pas
un camp comme dans l'autre comme aux
États-Unis c'est qu'on se sert de ça
pour faire douter tout le monde de tout
en fait et
ultimement mais ça vient qu'on doute du
régime de la démocratie on doute de la
véracité de ce modèle là et c'est ce que
cherche à faire la Chine quand je suis
allé rencontrer des gens où on se
penchait sur la question de la sécurité
numérique comment on fait pour des
déceler des fausses vidéos sur YouTube
on était en train d'éduquer la
population taïwanaise il y a des cours
là-dessus comment faire pour être
vigilant et je pense qu'on doit tous
être sensibilisé à cette question là
parce que autre le fait qu'on soit de
gauche ou de droite il y a cette
instrumentalisation là qui est très très
dangereuse
le dernier cadeau que j'ai reçu du
ministère des Affaires étrangères le
Kremlin nous invite chaque année pour la
nouvelle année et pendant la covid la
dernière année de covid il nous a envoyé
des cadeaux par la poste c'était une
tuque où il était écrit faites bien
attention à votre tête et sur la carte
qui était écrit le virus c'est la
désinformation ça vous donne une idée de
l'humour
bonsoir Monsieur Fillon
c'est super merci
quels sont les choix les plus difficiles
à faire pour exercer votre métier
alors on sait que ces choix là ont un
impact sur plusieurs dimensions de votre
vie et sur plusieurs dimensions de la
vie de vos proches comment ça se passe
pour vous Raphaël c'est clair que il y a
des répercussions très importantes sur
notre vie personnelle la vie de nos
proches aussi dans mon cas par exemple
on a un bébé qui est né il y a quelques
mois à peine c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
responsabilités pour ma conjointe et moi
puis on y pense évidemment en faisant
des déploiements combien de temps je
peux partir je peux pas partir tout le
temps je suis beaucoup parti ces
derniers mois mais j'essaie de garder
des périodes un peu plus courtes pour
pouvoir justement être à la maison aussi
assister à ces moments-là puis
contribuer c'est très très important je
pense ça fait partie de la réflexion
d'un peu tout le monde comment à la fois
vouloir aller sur le terrain c'est ce
qu'on veut tous faire on veut être
partout tout le temps je pense que c'est
la nature du métier c'est pour ça qu'on
fait ce métier là mais faut comprendre
aussi que que il y a une famille qui
fait des sacrifices pour venir avec nous
pour vivre l'expérience aussi parce que
c'est une expérience quand même
extraordinaire on a de la chance de
vivre que ce soit en Asie en Russie à
Paris ou à Washington mais en même temps
ça vient aussi avec son lot de sacrifice
et ça je pense qu'on en est tous
conscients et cette recherche de la
balance ça fait continuellement partie
de nos réflexions moi je trouve qu'il y
a une évolution pour les femmes quand
j'ai commencé ce métier beaucoup de
femmes me disaient tu dois choisir entre
ta carrière surtout comme correspondante
ou avoir une famille des enfants etc et
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui quand même les
couples sont beaucoup plus modernes moi
j'ai eu que j'ai eu deux enfants donc
j'ai quand même continué ma carrière
donc je trouve qu'il y a quand même une
évolution c'était évident qu'il y a des
sacrifices mais je pense que si on si on
équilibre les deux je pense qu'il y a
plus de davantage que de vous restez
dans un pays généralement trois ans
peut-être 4 ans donc le côté positif
c'est de faire vivre à ses enfants oui
il y a des sacrifices mais je pense
qu'on leur donne des avantages aussi
énormes mon fils parle russe moi mes
enfants ils se sont beaucoup attachés à
la Russie
je pense que les voyages la culture à
laquelle on les expose moi je sais que
c'est des sacrifices mais je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup plus d'avantages au bout
d'une affectation de faire 5 ans si on
était resté en Russie chaque année on
les consultait vous voulez vous restez
ok donc on pense pas parce qu'ils sont
heureux
et vous savez quoi être en famille à
l'étranger ça nous ouvre des portes
aussi qui seraient peut-être fermées les
familles qu'on rencontre les cours de
baleines les cours de sport
le système de garderie mais ça
sensibilise à la réalité des gens qu'on
interview aussi attention
avec Google Translate dans la salle
d'opération en Russie c'est quelque
chose alors on peut pas se laisser sans
parler d'une autre guerre c'est la
guerre au réchauffement climatique on
écoute la question de Madame lourd Denis
Jean
pouvez-vous nous parler d'un reportage
vous avez constaté les effets les
conséquences des changements climatiques
à l'étranger
qu'on a fait cet automne en Suisse donc
au cœur de l'Europe sur la fonte des
glaciers cette année les chercheurs ont
vu qu'en Suisse la superficie totale des
glacis a perdu 6% et ça se voit
clairement sur le terrain nous on est
allé au glacier du Mont minier on a
marché d'ailleurs marche assez
intéressant ça c'est nos intervenants
que vous voyez mais on a dit les suivre
aussi avec notre collègue
Santos c'est intéressant parce que à
travers cette marche là on voyait le
recul parce que les gens qui sont des
habitudes la montagne inscrivaient
l'année à laquelle se trouvait glacier
puis on voyait clairement le recul et ça
c'est un exemple qui est très frappant
mais il y en a eu tellement d'autres en
Europe cette année par exemple les
chaleurs extrêmes qu'on a vécu je pense
Marie a planter aussi ça a été très
chaud cet été en Europe
la plus chaude jamais enregistrée depuis
quand le calcul en France métropolitaine
donc en Europe c'est un sujet qui est
vraiment au cœur des préoccupations et
pour vous ASEB aux États-Unis on voit
actuellement ce qui se passe à
Californie mais si vous avez fait des
reportages qui m'ont peut-être le déni
des gens oui voilà c'est le c'est le
plus gros réservoir d'eau aux États-Unis
le Lacmé et puis en fait en parlant de
fonds des neiges il y a pas assez de
neige qui font pour alimenter le fleuve
du Colorado il y a quand même 7 États
qui dépendent de ce fleuve là en eau en
électricité et ce qui est assez
incroyable c'est que vous voyez à vue
d'oeil là le niveau de l'eau baissée
puis quand on parle aux gens ils se
plaignent un peu qui est plus de Marina
qui est plus de qui peuvent plus faire
du bateau comme avant il y a et donc il
y a un espèce de un déni on a
l'impression et et on était à Las Vegas
justement au casino les gens moi j'étais
complètement estomaquée de voir que il
faisait tellement froid tellement
c'était climatisé il fallait que je
porte un chandail alors qu'il faisait
très très chaud dehors donc il y a une
espèce de il y a un décalage entre la
réalité ce qui se passe réellement et
comment les gens vivent les gens veulent
continuer à arroser leur pelouse même si
on est en train de leur dire il y a plus
il y a plus d'eau quoi donc c'est assez
ça c'était c'était assez c'est tout
autre responsabilité que d'informer
sensibiliser les gens à cette époque
pour certains mais peut-être que les
mots sont on a beaucoup reprochés
monsieur gouttes d'exagérer le récemment
en parlant d'apocalypse dans mais vous
philippez en Asie c'est quoi le regard
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
5 mois mais je pense que mon travail de
sensibilisation a été fait autrement en
montrant qu'il y a des solutions il y a
pas de petites il y a pas de grandes
solutions on peut tous faire quelque
chose puis c'est hyper ludique tout le
monde s'en rend compte dès qu'on met les
pieds en visite à Taïwan et c'est camion
musicaux qui incite les gens qui doivent
aller porter leurs déchets eux-mêmes
là-bas c'est une façon de les
responsabiliser les sensibiliser à leur
propre consommation ils doivent payer
selon leur production et ça démontre
qu'on peut faire quelque chose puis je
pense que ça fait partie aussi de notre
travail on doit montrer les effets des
changements climatiques on doit
sensibiliser la population on doit
montrer qu'il y a de grandes et mais
aussi des petites solutions et qu'on
peut faire différentes sans en faire une
cause exacte exercer ça c'est on monte
c'est les fait l'importance rien fait
pour sentir au fait mais il y a une
urgence quand même je pense qu'il y a
une urgence climatique que la de plus en
plus il va y avoir de plus en plus de
tornades on voit il fait de plus en plus
chaud enfin non on a énormément senti en
Arizona au Nevada qui a vraiment cette
urgence là donc voilà ouais et plus on
voyage plus on constate à quel point
s'est répandu c'est ce que j'avais dit à
moi dans la même année alors j'ai fait
des reportages au cours de l'été en
France sur les chaleurs extrêmes la
sécheresse la police de l'eau qui
interdit aux gens d'arroser la pelouse
qui mesure qui vérifie ça c'est trop
vert c'est pas normal et puis quelques
semaines plus tard j'étais en
Afghanistan où il y a une sécheresse
historique là aussi dans les zones
agricoles crises alimentaires donc ça
exacerbe cette crise là la crise
humanitaire parfaite si vous voulez
alors que l'argent de la communauté
internationale se retire du pays mais on
les voit ces crises là un peu partout en
Occident dans les pays plus nordiques
dans les pays du Sud et ça se il y a des
cours de plus en plus
dernière question du public Monsieur
Michel lui-même veut savoir quel est
votre plus belle espoir de paix de
sécurité parce qu'avec tout ce qu'on a
décrit de détresse de misère de conflit
de crimes de guerre est-ce qu'il y a un
peu de beauté
dans ce monde
réponse à ses courses chacun un peu de
beauté
je vais essayer de faire ça rapidement
mais c'est que dans tout ce que l'on
couve je pense qu'on n'arriverait pas à
le faire puis à y retourner si on
n'avait pas ces moments-là mais toujours
des gens extraordinaires qui nous
montrent le meilleur de même dans le
pire et cette année entre autres en
Ukraine j'ai rencontré cette femme
Caterina qui a retrouvé un homme laissé
pour mort par les soldes russes près de
chez elle qui le prix qui le soignait
qu'il a hébergé caché pendant
l'occupation russe chez elle pendant 6
mois comme si c'était son propre fils ne
l'a jamais quitté pour qu'il puisse
survivre
on a beaucoup parlé de biodiversité avec
la COP15 j'ai eu la chance d'aller faire
un documentaire radio au Rwanda ou la
population de gorille de montagne espèce
menacée connaît une croissance c'est
aussi une bonne nouvelle dans le
contexte ça fait du bien
l'espoir il est partout j'en parlais en
début de l'émission il y a notre
collègue qui jouait du piano juste
écouter c'est notre là les yeux rivières
d'une jeune fille qu'on connaît pas dans
le métro les nouilles traditionnelles au
riz au bœuf épicé ou à Taïwan il y a du
beau il y a du bon on a sous-estimons
pas l'être humain partout où on se
trouve c'est lequel de vous en Pologne
je pense que vu des mères allaient
déposer leur enfant et retourner en
Ukraine oui j'y étais en fait ils sont
éliminer leurs enfants en sécurité et
elles sont elles ont décidé de retourner
en Ukraine pour défendre leur patrie
donc ça l'esprit de résilience de l'être
humain est très très fort on le voyait à
ce moment-là
je dirais les jeunes qui se battent
contre les les fusillades les tueries
beaucoup de jeunes s'impliquent de plus
en plus en politique et puis le dernier
reportage que j'ai fait c'était sur des
panneaux solaires sur d'anciennes mines
de charbon en Virginie et ça c'est
l'espoir et nous faisait
les Appalaches parce que les animaux
vont commencer à traverser vers le nord
et puis donc ça c'était notre d'espoir
pour vous depuis le début de l'émission
très mal sur la planète c'est vrai mais
en même temps moi je suis très
pragmatique très terre à terre mais je
crois aussi profondément en l'humain et
je pense que dans des situations de
crise parfois on sent que l'humanité
ressort et évite de tomber dans le
précipice puis on parlait de des gros
dossiers lourds comme l'avortement tout
à l'heure moi je suis toujours fasciné
de voir que les femmes sont de plus en
plus des actrices de changement elle
s'implique en politique elles ont un
poids politique important on l'avait aux
États-Unis mais je pense qu'on le voit
aussi ailleurs dans le monde et je pense
que il l'humanité puis à la femme il y a
les espoirs donc restons malgré tout
optimiste après on verra évidemment si
cette année sera moins pire que la
précédente mais il faut y croire moi je
m'étonne moi-même avec la réponse que je
vais vous donner parce que je suis pas
quelqu'un de très croyant mais moi ce
qui me rassure quand je quitte Ukraine
ou je quitte la Russie ou je quitte des
pays où il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
misères les gens s'accrochent à la
religion et des fois je les écoute puis
on l'entend souvent les reportages que
Dieu nous protège que la volonté de Dieu
mais les gens s'accrochent à ça et ça
les aide et c'est très vrai c'est pas
juste des paroles quand vous allez les
entendre dans nos reportages les gens
s'accrochent à ça et ça leur permet de
trouver une force je les juge pas
parfois mais il y a quelque chose et
comme disait tous mes collègues l'humain
est profondément bon
on le voit on parle beaucoup de ce qu'il
y a de mauvais mais
les gens il y a beaucoup de beauté dans
le chaos aussi et ça c'est ça nous
inspire mais c'est sûr que ce qui se
passe en ce moment est assez pris alors
le mot de la fin je laisse peut-être
affiler parce que vous dans le fond vous
êtes en début de mandat dans un
continent extrêmement important et un
continent extrêmement important qui aura
un rôle plus important je pense et qui
aura aussi des liens qui vont changer
dans la prochaine année par rapport à ce
que vous couvrez en Europe et aussi aux
États-Unis j'ai hâte de découvrir ce
monde là avec vous alors on vous
souhaite le meilleur à tous les 6 on va
continuer de vous suivre sur le terrain
c'est là qu'il faut être au bon moment
ça va être merci de votre générosité de
votre ouverture ce soir merci beaucoup
alors c'est là-dessus que se termine
notre émission spéciale merci donc
encore une fois Tamara Frédéric Hazeb
Philippe Raphaël et Marie-Eve vous les
avez connu un petit peu plus ce soir
demain en direct à la radio de
Radio-Canada ici première distinguer
rencontre devant le public les aussi les
correspondants les correspondants
là-dessus bonne soirée au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]